Ihr seid ja schon ganz schön früh wach, Leute.
Die ersten haben schon 8.24 Uhr, das ist vor 20 Minuten, hier im Chat rumgezweppt.
Was ist denn da los, ey?
Du bist heute tatsächlich nicht der erste.
Seit 6.30 Uhr.
Oh nee, das wird zu früh.
Ich bin früher immer 5.45 Uhr aufgestanden, als ich noch täglich da nach Frankfurt geeiert bin,
dass ich zu halbwegs normalen Zeiten anfangen konnte und wieder auch daheim war.
Aber das mache ich nicht mehr.
Das ist zu früh.
Jetzt stehe ich meistens so 7.20 Uhr oder so in dem Dreh auf und dann fahre ich 8.20 Uhr.
Es ist nicht wild, weil dadurch, dass ich nur noch einmal die Woche nach Frankfurt fahren muss,
verliere ich nicht so viel Zeit mit Hin und Zurückfahren und dann geht das insgesamt halbwegs unter dem Strich so auf.
Seht und danke für den Zapp.
Ansonsten hätte es halt nicht funktioniert.
Das ist ein weiterer Vorteil von mehr Home Office.
Man ist schlicht und ergreifend wacher.
Dementsprechend bekommt man auch mehr mit.
Man ist irgendwo auch natürlich motivierter, macht weniger Zeug kaputt und sonst was.
Das ist eigentlich für alle beteiligt, nur besser.
Also ich bin 5.45 Uhr früher aufgestanden und war dann immer so, weiß ich gar nicht, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht mehr genau.
Ich habe Tweets gepostet von, wo ich im Dunklen in Frankfurt über die Brücke gelaufen bin.
Da musst du mal auf Twitter suchen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich 5.45 Uhr, da bin ich wahrscheinlich dann 6.20 Uhr oder so gefahren, mich beeilt.
Dann war ich wahrscheinlich so 7 oder so, so 7.50 Uhr, 7.50 Uhr bis 7 Uhr in der Firma, so irgendwie in dem Dreh.
6.50 Uhr, 6.50 Uhr bis 7.50 Uhr, je nachdem.
Eigentlich total früh, wenn man sich das mal so überlegt.
Heute bin ich so 8 Uhr, heute bin ich eineinhalb Stunden später da und bin viel, viel wacher und kann es halt machen,
weil ich die anderen Tage mir das Hin- und Zurückfahren spare.
Ansonsten, wenn ich jedes Mal da hin- und Zurückfahren müsste und das ich erst um 9 Uhr da wäre,
dann müsste ich ja sonst, oder 8 Uhr irgendwas da, dann müsste ich ja bis 18 Uhr da rumhocken oder so.
Das ist ja auch nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Da kann es ja sonst nichts mehr machen.
Also das ist schon mit Homeoffice für alle Beteiligten das Beste.
Ich spare mir das blöde Hin- und Hergefahren, dafür mache ich mehr und ich habe keine Minusstunden.
Das ist eigentlich besser, das ist eigentlich das beste Beispiel dafür, warum das gut ist.
Du machst mehr, was ja für deinen Arbeitgeber von Vorteil sein sollte und du selbst machst auch noch weniger Minusstunden
oder sowas, weil du halt zu normalen Zeiten heimkommen willst.
Ehrlich für alle Beteiligten das Beste.
Und das lustige daran ist, ich habe das ja bei mir zumindest auf der aktuellen Arbeit,
aber das hat sich ja eh demnächst in 14 Tagen oder auch nicht mal 14 Tagen, in 10 Tagen,
na 14 Tage kommt schon hin, erledigt.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen, ich habe nebenbei einen Chat gelesen.
Ja also wie gesagt, mein aktueller Job hat sich an 14 Tagen erledigt.
Da haben sie mir auch immer auf die Frage hin so nach dem Motto, ja, man ist fitter, man macht mehr und so.
Da haben sie nie was dagegen gesagt, das waren eigentlich alle der Meinung, ja das ist so,
aber trotzdem sollen die Leute wieder 50% anwesend sein, was ist total widersprüchlich.
Also auf der einen Seite sagt man, oh das läuft ja richtig gut und besser mit Homeoffice,
auf der anderen Seite will man es nicht und die Leute sollen wieder anrücken.
Also insofern macht es keinen Sinn, was ja auch der Hauptgrund für mich war,
zu sagen, ich hau ab.
Bisschen Office ist okay, ja, einmal die Woche reicht mir genug.
Du musst, ich weiß gar nicht inwieweit das möglich ist.
Du musst doch mittlerweile überall Zeiterfassung machen, oder?
Also ich muss ganz normal Zeiterfassung machen, das kann ich euch sagen.
Ja, sagt er.
Also, ich glaube es ist mittlerweile sogar Pflicht, dass man Zeiterfassung machen muss.
Außer vielleicht in super krassen hippen Zoomer-Startups,
die arbeiten dann eh von 5 Uhr bis 23 Uhr
und finden es noch geil.
Weil ich das ja auch nicht schlimm finde, kann ja jeder machen.
Ich mache ja auch quasi den ganzen Tag nichts anderes,
wie Zeug am Computer machen, allerdings nicht unbedingt zwangsläufig nur für meinen Arbeitgeber.
Da mache ich die normale Zeit und danach mache ich Sachen, die mich interessieren
und das Coole ist, dass ich ja glücklicherweise sogar schon auf der Arbeit
oftmals Sachen machen kann, die mich interessieren.
Zum Beispiel im neuen Job werde ich hoffentlich ein bisschen mehr Kubernetes-Stells machen können,
was mich ja aktuell interessiert.
Das wäre auf jeden Fall nice.
Führungskräfte machen keine Zeiterfassung.
Ich dachte eigentlich, es müssten mittlerweile alle Zeiterfassung machen.
Es heißt nicht, dass Zeiterfassung unbedingt an irgendeinem Kartenstempel-Ding passieren muss.
Es kann auch sein, dass es irgendein Zeiterfassungssystem gibt,
wo man seine Zeiten einträgt, manuell.
Das kann auch durchaus sein, aber ich glaube es ist nicht so, dass mittlerweile
wirklich alle verpflichtet sind, in irgendeiner Art und Weise Zeiterfassung zu machen.
Ich dachte eigentlich schon.
Wir haben nicht SHP, wir haben irgendwas anderes.
Ich zeige euch mal, was wir hatten.
Das sieht aus wie 1995.
Ne, gibt es gar keine, gibt es gar keine.
Also was wir als Zeiterfassung hatten, ist das hier.
Interflex-Zeiterfassung.
Da gucken wir uns mal ein paar Screenshots an, da werdet ihr sehen.
Es sieht aus wie von 1995.
Nach so modern sieht das bei uns aber nicht aus.
So sieht das aus, ja.
So sieht das aus.
Hallo?
Was auch immer ich hier gerade geöffnet habe hier.
So sieht das aus bei uns.
Wie 1995.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich hier...
Provinz, BZIT.
Okay, keine Ahnung, irgendwas Italienisches.
Oder, ne, ach was auch immer.
So sieht ungefähr genauso sieht das bei uns auch aus.
Also genauso sieht das Interface aus.
Das ist halt wirklich hässlich wie die Nacht.
Das sieht nach JQuery UI aus.
Ich finde das sieht sogar noch älter als JQuery UI aus.
Anscheinend gibt es davon auch ein bisschen, wenn ich das jetzt so mir richtig angucke, auch neuere Versionen.
Aber ne, ne, ne, das haben wir nicht.
Also unser sieht genauso hässlich aus, wie ich es euch gerade gezeigt habe.
Ja gut, das ist ja auch Zeiterfassung dann in irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Ob das rechtlich konform ist, keine Ahnung, da habe ich keinen Plan von.
Zumindest in irgendeiner Art und Weise Zeiterfassung muss, glaube ich, mittlerweile gemacht werden.
Eures sieht so ähnlich aus, okay.
Doktor DSGVO.
Geile Domain, Alter.
Was ist das Scheiß Domain?
Ist ja geil, Alter.
Das ist nice.
Doktor DSGVO.
Okay, so sieht es bei euch aus.
Okay, das sieht ja mal nach typischem SAP Abfuck aus, wenn ich mir das so angucke.
Ihr wisst ja noch nicht mal, wo ich was eintragen muss für Zeiterfassung.
Es sieht aus, wie Excel in kompliziert war.
Zeiterfassung in Excel.
Irgendwelche Markus Laufner Schreime sind eine MSS-Geltern.
Sei mal vor, dass es keine Excel-Datenbank ist, immerhin.
Es geht immer noch schlimmer.
Wenn man denkt, es geht immer schlimmer, doch es geht meistens noch schlimmer.
Hansalock.
Das hört sich an wie so ein Pflasterhersteller.
Zeiterfassung. Gucken wir mal an, wie sieht es bei dir aus?
Das ist so hässlich, da gibt es doch nicht mal Screenshots von.
Ich meine, von unserem System gibt es wenigstens hässliche Screenshots.
Und bei KioKons SAP-Ding auch.
Aber bei Hansalock gibt es anscheinend nicht mal Screenshots.
Ja, wir haben schon...
Wir haben schon wirklich ziemliche Schrott-Software teilweise im Einsatz.
Ich mache mir übrigens keine Illusionen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber irgendwie besser wird,
was da eingesetzt wird.
Ich glaube, dass es bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber irgendwie besser wird.
Was da eingesetzt wird.
Ich meine, das ist auch so ein richtig alt-oldschool-Boomer-Laden.
Die haben da wahrscheinlich auch Zeiterfassungs-Dinger von...
Das haben wir schon geguckt.
Zeiterfassungs-Software von 1985 oder so.
PCI...
Gen5 Triumphs.
Okay, das interessiert mich tatsächlich.
Da kann ich sogar zwei Sponsorings ertragen.
Wobei ich wahrscheinlich mal davon ausgehe, dass sie nicht worth sind.
Weil selbst mein aktuelles nutze ich nicht mal im Ansatzweise aus.
SAP, Aaron.
Man kann bestimmt auch deswegen irgendeinen Microsoft-Service machen.
Mich würde nicht wundern, wenn Microsoft sogar auch irgendeinen Zeiterfassungs-Service hat.
Microsoft-Zeiterfassung.
Zeiterfassung in Microsoft Teams.
Working Hours.
Wisst ihr?
Das ist...
Ach, das ist...
Irgendein Schrott.
Irgendein Schrott im Windows Store.
Zeiterfassung für Teams.
Dynamics.
Was zum Teufel ist Dynamics 365?
Enterprise Resource Planning.
Ah, das ist...
Okay, das ist für Manager Gatschi Gasm.
Wo die richtig scharf werden bei...
Wenn sie so Charts sehen, dann werden die richtig heiß.
Dann stehen die drauf.
Es ist zwar egal, ob die Charts irgendwas Sinnvolles sagen,
aber ich habe den Eindruck, wenn Manager Charts sehen,
dann ist egal, was auf dem Chart drauf ist,
dann ist Assut Gatschi Gasm time.
Die meisten Charts sind halt auch komplett unsinnig.
Manchmal erkennst du in den Charts dann weniger,
als du mit irgendwelchen Daten erkennen würdest,
wenn die nicht gut gemacht sind.
Ist das der Senior?
Ja, richtig.
Richtig.
Ja.
Das ist der Senior.
Ist es?
So sieht es aus.
Am 3.4.
Was war das Microsoft?
Weiß nicht.
Also eine Woche noch.
Zwei Wochen noch.
Und dann...
Das übernächste Wochen, wenn man mal denkt,
dann ist hier halt hier Montag.
Da geht es dann los.
Was wir jetzt noch nicht gesehen haben,
dieلStones.
DieLLStones.
Gute Idee.
Gute Idee, dieLStones.
DieLStones.
Man muss doch einfach
dieSkalierung anpassen.
Ich meine, man kann logarithmisch
Producer, dann gehts cheaper.
Computer, dann gehts einfach schneller.
Wenn du das Bein bei derStone auf dem breeding
verheißt hast
ist das deflectiv.
Das wird dann auf den computer
das wird dann nicht verlongt.
Das ist dann aber nicht, weil es quasi immer
so, dass in 10er-Schritten
dieSkala ändert.
Du müsstest dann quasi
negativ logarithmisch
skalieren, also quasi
immer durchzählen anstatt
malzählen. Dann hast du eine Steigung
in deinem Graph drinne
die eigentlich keine ist.
Hab ich zwar noch nie gesehen, dass
das einer macht, aber
gehen müsste das, ja.
Einfach, einfach
diagonal skalieren, dann hat man
alles dabei.
Kommt auf den Mount Everest.
So, dann machen wir mal das übliche.
Eine Sache gucken wir jeden
Samstag, dass ich ein bisschen
meckern kann. Nein, wir gucken uns nicht
die Issues von
vom Vier-Champ an, der mir
immerhin schon 53 Sterne hat.
Wir gucken uns
aktuell mal schnell
durchgescrollt, wo ist es denn?
Products Trends?
Ganz schnell die GitHub
Trends dieser Woche anschauen,
was wahrscheinlich wiederum komplett
nur AI, AI
und ein bisschen Krypto-Zeug ist.
Gehst du, siehst du, geht schon los,
geht schon los.
AI.
Eine Kohle,
was auch immer.
Oh, man kann den Python jetzt zu
WebAssembly kompilieren, wahrscheinlich.
Vermute ich mal.
Irgendwie sowas. Warum auch immer ein Mann
Python im Browser machen will. Na gut.
AI.
Keine Ahnung, was das
sein soll.
Hat er, hat auch sehr, sehr viel.
Okay. AI.
Äh.
Erspack.
Geiler Name.
A fast Rust-based
Web-Buntler. Ah, excellent.
Blazingly fast, natürlich.
Was sonst? Kommt das denn in der
Blazing, nein.
Ey, wie, ein Rust-Projekt, wo einer
nicht Blazingly fast reinschreibt.
Cute.
Cute-Krabbe am Start.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, was es
ist. Was ist es denn? Was bin, was sehe ich hier
überhaupt? Ah, quasi sowas wie
wie Webpack,
in Rust oder sowas?
Oder wie, oder was soll das sein?
Extremely fast.
Nicht Blazingly fast.
Bringt alle...
Le...
Also ich vermute, dass es sowas
ähnliches wie Webpack ist.
Was auch immer.
Irgendwas mal wieder rewritten in Rust.
Aber Erspack,
geiler Name.
Okay,
AI, AI, AI,
AI, meine
Güte, AI.
Cloud-Fat-Tunnel, okay,
Liste, AI.
Irgendwas
für Telefonnummern, AI.
Alter,
dieses Mal war ja 90%
AI.
90% der Sache AI.
Es wird ja, es wird,
es wird ja jede Woche mehr.
Was auch immer.
Jet-GPT ist
raus, ich weiß.
Warum ich O2 offen habe?
Weil O2 4 Tage, muss man jetzt
sagen, gebraucht hat, es geht ja mittlerweile,
weil O2 4 Tage gebraucht hat,
mein Account
das Login
zu fixen. Ich habe mich
registriert bzw. ich habe eine SIM-Karte
bestellt bei O2. SIM-Karte
kam auch an, ich meine, du kannst das Ganze ja...
Man kann das Ganze ja hier, hier verfolgen,
ja.
Also,
mein Login-Account ging nicht.
Und die haben 4 Tage dafür
gebraucht,
bis das wieder funktioniert hat.
Deswegen haben wir uns das letzte Mal hier
O2 angeguckt. Man muss halt sagen, sie haben es
hinbekommen. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht
damit gerechnet, dass sie es noch
quasi diese Woche
schaffen, aber sie haben es hinbekommen.
Am Freitag irgendwann
ging es dann.
Oder am Samstag, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ich glaube,
am Freitag irgendwann ging es dann.
Könnte es die Welt, und das ist natürlich eine Frage,
so helserische Fähigkeiten,
naja.
Also, ich denke schon,
dass es in vielen Bereichen Anwendung
finden wird, und ich denke auch, dass es auch viele
Bereiche Auswirkungen haben wird.
Ansonsten, finde ich, macht es nicht so viel
Sinn, diese ganzen Entwicklungen miteinander
zu vergleichen. Ich meine, klar, ich kann sagen,
was war so wichtig...
Erst wurden Dampfmaschinen erfunden, dann wurde
das Internet erfunden, dann wurde AI erfunden.
Da gab es ja noch beliebig viele andere
Sachen dazwischen, die auch wichtig waren.
Die haben alle die Welt
verändert auf
ihre eigene Art und Weise.
Ob das jetzt...
mit Chat-AIs ähnlich sein wird
ein Schimmer.
Also, was heißt mit Chat-AIs?
Nicht mit AI an sich.
Ich glaube, da fehlt mir die große Vision
dahinter aktuell. Ich meine,
ich sehe auch,
dass das potentiell
einen großen
Anwendungsbereich hat.
Je nachdem, wie gut
die Dinger sind.
Beziehungsweise, dass man die jetzt
ja eigentlich schon vermehrt einsetzen
könnte, aber es bei vielen Leuten noch nicht
angekommen ist. Du kannst zum Beispiel Antworten
für E-Mails und so viel einfacher
mit Chat-GPT generieren
als selber schreiben.
Kannst du auch sagen, sollst du das besonders höflich machen.
Sag dem besonders höflich ab.
Dann kriegst du eine E-Mail. Das ist tatsächlich ganz
praktisch. Ich bin mir auch relativ sicher, dass
Chat-GPT
bessere Stellenanzeigen generieren würde,
als die Durchschnittspersonalabteilung.
Die sind
nicht Pfeiferder genug dafür.
Das müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
Wollen wir das? Leute, das testen wir jetzt.
Wir lassen uns für
ein Senior-Linux-
Engineer eine
Anzeige generieren. Das machen wir jetzt.
Probieren wir es mal aus.
Da muss ich mich einloggen. Dazu muss ich euch mal kurz
ausbauen. Ich hoffe, dass ich
mein Passwort
noch hab.
Display-Capture aus.
AI.
Chat.
GPT.
Login.
Okay.
Passworte.
Scheiße.
وال assumed
Passewort nicht mehr.
Moment, ich guck mal kurz
auf mein Handy. Ich habe das Passwort
auf meinem Handy geschmeichert.
Passwörter.
Open AI.
Hier ist es.
Ah ja.
Okay.
Alles klar, ich bin eingeloggt.
Dann.
Okay, ich mach euch wieder an.
Also, probieren wir das mal.
Ich habe doch, klar habe ich einen Passwortmanager.
Aber nicht hier
auf meinem Streaming Kiste unter dem
Account. Ich hätte auf dem zweiten Display
gucken können anstatt auf dem Handy.
So.
Also,
genriere
eine DELLEN
Anzeige für
Senior
Senior Linux
So Chat, ihr müsst mir jetzt
ein bisschen helfen. Was soll das?
Was wollen wir haben?
Für einen Senior
Linux Engineer mit
folgenden Anforderungen.
Okay, was soll der haben?
Erstmal nichts? Okay.
Okay, ihr habt recht. Erstmal nichts.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Erfahrung in Cloud. Gucken wir mal. Generiere eine
Anzeige für einen Senior Linux Engineer.
Er muss agil sein.
Cloud und agil. Genau.
So, was sagt der Chat GPT?
Wir suchen derzeit einen erfahrenen Senior Linux Engineer,
der sich unserem dynamischen und innovativen
IT Team anschließt.
Als Senior Linux Engineer sind sie für die Verwaltung
und Wartung unserer Linusinfrastruktur auf Tragung
zur Verbesserung der System und sich...
Ja gut, sie ist halt sehr 0815, aber was soll
der Chat GPT aufschreiben?
Okay, das ist
bescheuert geschrieben.
Anforderungen. Bachelorabschluss
oder verwandte Bereiche.
Das ist auch komisch geschrieben.
Mindestens 5 Jahre
Erfahrung in der... Okay, ja.
Erfahrung, Implementierung wie VMWare
oder KVM.
Sagt Chat GPT jetzt
einfach?
Tiefgreifende Kenntnisse in Linux-basierten
Netzwerken, Protokollen und Technologien.
Das ergibt auch keinen
Sendersatz. Erfahrung in der Automatisierung
von Aufgaben und Entwicklung von Skripten.
Ja, okay.
Kenntnisse in Cloud-Technologien wie AWS
Azure, Google Cloud, Plattform von Vorteilen.
Ausgezeichnet...
Okay, seriously?
Das ist zwar eine 0815-Stellenanzeige,
die ist aber auch nicht schlechter als die,
die man sonst so findet.
Wir bieten
wettbewerbsfähige Gehälter,
großzügige Sozialleistung.
Okay, wir bieten...
Moment, wir bieten
einen
wöchentlichen
Obstkorb.
Da muss ich schreiben
der Stellanzeige hinzufügen oder sowas.
Ich hab mich übrigens auch
verschrieben.
Das ist natürlich toll,
ja.
Füge das der
Stellanzeige hinzu.
Okay, ich schreib das jetzt mal
ganz umgangssprachlich, mal gucken, ob wahrscheinlich nicht.
Füge das mit dem
Obstkorb
der Stellanzeige hinzu.
Bin mal gespannt, ob es das checkt.
Okay, nice.
Alles klar.
So, wo
kommt der Obstkorb jetzt?
Ja,
auf jetzt.
Das ist alles das Gleiche.
Wo kommt der Obst...
Teamorientierte Arbeitsweise,
das hatten wir oben noch nicht, ja?
Doch, hatten wir auch schon.
Hier, also, zu unseren
Sozialleistungen gehört
auch ein wöchentlicher Obst- oder Früchtekorb,
um das Wohlbefinden
unserer Mitarbeiter zu fördern
und sie bei einer gesunden Ernährung
zu unterstützen.
Nice, das ist doch, das ist doch schon mal was.
Obstkorb, so.
Weitere Anforderungen
der Stellanzeige
hinzufügen.
Okay, was muss unser Typ haben?
Unser Admin, was muss der haben?
Der muss agil sein.
Der muss Cloud-Native,
was auch immer, was auch immer.
Wir schreiben jetzt einfach mal Cloud-Native.
Cloud-Native,
Def, Sec,
Bis, Pin,
Obst.
Wir schreiben mal ein bisschen Bullshit rein, mal gucken,
wie es damit klarkommt.
Def, Sec, Bis,
Pin, Obst.
Wir wenden schon alles zusammen, ja?
Erfahrung
mit MongoDB.
Natürlich, wir können alles mal rein.
MongoDB und
NoSQL.
Und NoSQL.
Kubernetes.
Windows-Erfahrung
unerwünscht.
Probieren wir das mal aus.
Mal gucken, ob das das checkt,
dass ich jemanden haben will, der kein,
der Windows scheiße findet.
Okay.
Muss Windows
Scheiße finden.
Mal gucken, was Check-GPD da
daraus macht. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Gehen dann los
und 24-7
am Rechner sitzen.
Unverheiratet.
So.
Ähm.
Cobalt.
Okay, lassen wir das erstmal.
Was?
Wie jetzt?
Check-GPD
nicht mitdenken.
Trotzdem,
trotzdem hinzufügen.
Was?
Oh, man. Alter.
Check-GPD ist ja
korrekter, ist ja korrekter als
Twitter, man.
Okay, in.
Aber
hier ist das
gesetzlich
erlaubt.
Ja, ja.
Check-GPD, genau, genau.
Trotzdem
hinzufügen.
Jetzt
denkt's. Okay, es muss überlegen.
Es muss überlegen.
Okay.
Check-GPD korrekter
als Twitter. Alles
confirmed.
Gut, dann,
dann nicht. Okay. Also
müssen wir das mit Kinderlos und
unverheiratet draus machen.
Muss Windows scheiße finden.
Windows ist
sehr emotional.
Alter.
Okay.
Lassen wir das, lassen wir das mit
Kinderlos noch weg.
Mal gucken. Ich mein, irgendwie
muss es den Kram ja fressen.
Was, was zum Teufel?
Was ist denn jetzt das Problem?
Okay.
Okay, dann kann er
vergessen das
von eben so.
Okay, kein Bock mehr, das wird zu doof.
Wir könnten jetzt, wir könnten
jetzt irgendeinen eigenen Promf zusammen
wurschteln.
Check-GPD Developer Mode.
Okay.
Okay, was, was
was wir mal?
Pulli
Featured Filter.
Was?
Okay, das, das
heißt ich muss das da.
Warte mal,
Moment, wie funktioniert das?
Das ist
das muss ich da quasi als Prompt
reinkopieren oder wie?
Das muss ich da quasi reinkopieren.
Okay.
The fuck?
Na dann.
Okay, dann können wir das ja von da oben wieder
von da oben wieder reinkopieren.
Generiere eine
Stellenanzeige, wir machen das gleiche nochmal.
Generiere eine Stellenanzeige mit
als Lennoxiner.
Und wir schreiben
wir bieten einen
wöchentlichen Obstkorb.
Folgende Anforderungen.
Moment, wo habe ich das hier?
Ja, erstmal so.
Okay, dann muss ich das Ganze jetzt auf
Deutsch.
Jetzt kriegen wir, jetzt kriegen wir das Ganze
in Deutsch.
Alles klar, so.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, jetzt gucken wir mal ob da
der ganze Mist mit dem Obstkorb
auch drinne steht.
Ich glaube,
jetzt hat er, jetzt hat er das andere aber
wieder nicht mehr dabei.
Das hätte jetzt nur in Englisch dann funktioniert.
Na geil.
Attraktiv ist geil. Und außerdem
einen wöchentlichen Obstkorb.
Okay.
Jetzt mag er wieder nicht.
Ach doch, okay.
Darüber hinaus suchen wir noch einen agilen
Kandidaten mit Erfahrung
in DevSec bis FinOs.
Das andere ist doch deutlich
besser. Hey, wir suchen einen verdammt
genialen Senior Linux Engineer,
der Windows als das Scheißsystem
betrachtet.
Das ist doch schon mal deutlich
besser, der Output.
Wir suchen einen verdammt genialen Senior
Linux Engineer, der Windows
als das Scheißsystem betrachtet.
Das ist es. Wenn du ein
Linux Guru bist, der jeden Befehl wie
ein Boss beherrscht,
dann bist du bei uns genau
richtig. Du solltest die Cloud wie
die Rückseite deiner Hand kennen.
Okay.
Und das Zeug wie
Kubernetes und NoSQL besser beherrschen
als deine eigene Muttersprache.
Wir wollen einen Entwickler, der es liebt
zu sein und DevSec bis FinObs
in den Griff zu kommen. Aber hey, lass dich
nicht von dieser bescheidenen
Stellenbeschreibung einstehen. Wir suchen
noch jemand, der bereit ist, die Schicht
24-7 durchzuarbeiten ohne Rücksicht auf
Freunde, Familie oder andere Verpflichtung.
Es ist uns auch egal, ob du
verheiratet bist oder Kinder hast. Wir wollen
jemand, der nur Augenverlierungs hat und die
beste Ergebnisse... Leute, das
ist doch mit Abstand die beste Stellenanzeige,
die ich in letzter Zeit gesehen habe.
Die ist wenigstens ehrlich.
Ohne steht scheiß Windows
dabei.
Das finde ich gut.
Habt ihr noch irgendwelche Ideen,
was wir hinzufügen könnte?
Um das Ganze noch ein bisschen
zu verfeinern.
Wir bieten... Okay.
Die Gehaltsspanne
oder...
Kann man das für die Ewigkeit ausrücken?
Ich kann es Copy-Pasten.
Wir können es in der Textdatei Copy-Pasten.
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht mehr.
Chat, GPT,
Linux, Engineer.
Das ist doch schon eine gute Antwort.
Wir bieten ein Gehalt
von...
25.000
Euro im Jahr.
Und...
keine
Altersvorsorge.
Wir bieten eine
wettbewerbsfähige
Vergütung.
Wir glauben, dass Altersvorsorge
völlig überbewertet ist, dass unsere
Mitarbeiter viel besser daran tun,
ihre Zeit und Energie in ihre Arbeit
zu investieren. Schließlich ist es die
Arbeit, das Ungewisse in die Arbeit zu setzen.
Anstatt sich mit langweiligen Themen wie
Rentenversorgung...
Das sind irgendwelche Ami-Geschichten.
Bitte beachten Sie, dass wir sehr hohe Erwartungen
an unsere Mitarbeiter haben.
Und dass wir nur nach den Besten suchen
für 25.000 Euro im Jahr. Natürlich.
Wenn Sie nicht bereit sind, ihre gesamte Zeit
und Energie in die Arbeit zu investieren
und sich mit Windows-System
herumzuschlagen...
was?
Okay, ja.
Wir suchen noch eine Person
die Kinderlosunfall hat.
Und rund um die Uhr am Rechner sitzt.
Wir warten, dass Sie agil sind und Erfahrung
mit Cloud-Native-Dev, MongoDB haben.
Wenn Sie Windows mögen, dann sollten Sie
besser weiterziehen. Denn wir möchten
jemand, der Windows als das akzeptiert,
was es ist. Totaler Mist.
Sehr gut!
So gefallen mir
die Antworten von chat.gpt
deutlich besser.
Okay, dann machen wir noch das rein,
was in jeder Stellenanzeige rein steht.
Wir sind das beste
Unternehmen, das es gibt.
Wir feiern
uns
regelmäßig
selber ab.
Kannst du den Reddit-Link posten?
Jo.
Er hat schon.
Unsere Mitarbeiter sind die Besten
der Besten und wir feiern uns regelmäßig
selbst. Und jeder, der für uns arbeitet,
sollte sich glücklich schätzen. Wir haben
die besten Gehälter und unsere Mitarbeiter
sind alle... Ah ja, natürlich.
Der Stellenanzeige
hinzufügen.
Was?
Ist mir egal.
Jetzt vorbei.
Broken.
Oh man.
Nein.
Ist nicht helbvoll.
Trotzdem.
Macht das trotzdem.
Egal, wird nicht funktionieren.
Okay. Also wir haben jetzt eine tolle
Stellenanzeige generiert.
Wir haben jetzt
eine tolle Stellenanzeige generiert.
Das kopieren wir auch nochmal mit rein.
Daraus lässt sich
sicherlich eine
ganz tolle Stellenanzeige generieren.
Wobei ich ja das erste
mit Abstand am besten finde.
Ja. Wir suchen
ein, das fängt schon so geil an,
wir suchen einen verdammt genialen
Senior Linux Engineer, der Windows
als das Scheißsystem betrachtet,
das es ist.
Wenn du jeden Befehl wie
einen Boss beherrschst.
Das ist schonmal dann verkehrt.
Exzellent, gut.
Haben wir schon perfekte Stellenanzeige
generiert heute.
Easy.
Ich glaube, da wird
sich jetzt jeder
drauf bewerben.
Seit wann kann Notepad Emojis?
Seit Windows 11
unseres seitdem Notepads
irgendeine UWP-VinUI Anwendung ist.
Sieht man auch am Font-Rendering,
dass es nicht mehr das alte
Notepad ist.
Also das Font-Rendering ist anders.
Wenn du das alte Notepad
zum Beispiel vergleichst
mit dem neuen,
dann siehst du, dass das Font-Rendering ein bisschen anders ist.
Das ist eigentlich das beste Hinweis drauf,
dass sie was Neues verwenden.
Gut.
Beste Stellenanzeige.
Jetzt wäre interessant.
Okay, das können wir tatsächlich machen.
Das machen wir. Komm, das machen wir jetzt noch schnell.
Wir fragen jetzt, ob Chat-GP, die die Stellenanzeige
verbessern kann.
Bitte verbessere
vor allem
die Stellenanzeige.
Verbessere
folgende Stellenanzeige.
Mal gucken. Jetzt kommt so 0815
Corporate Gelaber raus, wahrscheinlich.
Wir suchen einen erfahrenen
Linux-Experten, der sich in der IT-Welt auskennt
und wie kein anderer.
Wenn du ein leidenschaftlicher Anhänger
von Linux bist und dich in der Cloud so wie mit
Kubernetes Neues kennst, dann bist du
agil, aber
wir suchen noch jemanden, der bereit ist.
Okay, das ist jetzt halt langweilig.
Das andere war viel, viel besser.
Also, ich fand
das viel besser, dass die einen
verdammt genialen Linux-Senior-Engineer
suchen, der Windows als das Scheißsystem
betrachtet, dass es ist.
Okay, okay, okay.
Das Letzte machen wir jetzt noch.
Die Stellenanzeige muss
agiler sein.
Agiler?
Agiler und hipper.
Was ist das?
Wie agiler und hipper
hipper klingt.
Senior Linux-Engineer
wanted. Hey,
bist du bereit für die Herausforderung als
unser neuer Senior
Linux-Engineer? Wir suchen jemanden,
der sich mit Linux wie ein Boss auskennt
und der auch in der Cloud zuhause
ist. Wenn du Kubernetes
als deine Muttersprache, dann bist du
bei uns. Wir suchen jemanden, der agil und
flexibel ist, der ja bla. Wir
brauchen jemanden, der nicht
nur die Schicht rockt.
Oh, cringe, Alter.
Wir brauchen nicht nur jemanden, der die Schicht
rockt, sondern der auch unser
Team... Das könnte
eins zu eins von irgendeiner billigen
Marketing-Agentur kommen.
Richtig, richtig, PaintsChamp.
Wir suchen jemanden, der es
liebt, neue Technologien zu erforschen
und sich ständig weiterzubilden.
Bei uns geht es um Leidenschaft und
Engagement. Wir erwarten nicht, dass du
bla, bla, bla. Wir wissen
jedoch, dass manchmal Überstunden nötig
sind, um die besten Ergebnisse zu erzählen.
Wenn du bereit bist, mit uns bis spät
in die Nacht zu arbeiten, um unsere Kunden
glücklich zu machen, dann bist du der Richtige
für uns. Wir sind eine junge und dynamische
Firma und suchen jemanden, der genauso agil
und hip ist wie wir.
Leute, da würde ich mich im Leben
nicht drauf bewerben. Wir wollen
jemanden, der unserer Vision teilt und sich darauf
bewerben. Also ohne Scheiß,
die erste Stellenanzeige,
die ist so
bescheuert, da könnte man sich fast schon
drauf bewerben. Die ist so dämlich und so
und so anders, weil
sie eben,
ja, wahrscheinlich rechtlich
nicht konform ist, aber halt irgendwie
mich noch eher anspricht, als der
rechtliche
Krampf hier.
Was finde ich?
Windows Scheißsystem
betrachtet, das ist
bewirbt sich darauf, dich
zu kennen. Ja, sehr schön.
Okay. So, Leute, wir gucken uns
jetzt mal YouTube-Videos an.
Wieso sollte die nicht gesetzlich okay sein?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man
reinschreiben darf, dass Windows ein Scheißsystem
ist und sowas.
Man, wahrscheinlich wird dich Microsoft nicht
verklagen. Ja, auch, dass wir jemanden
haben wollen, der unverheiratet
ist und keine Kinder hat,
das ist auf jeden Fall gesetzlich nicht
erlaubt.
Ja,
es ist uns auch egal, ob du verheiratet bist oder
Kinder hast. Okay, okay, das hat sie
schon ein bisschen, das wurde schon ein bisschen
besser geschrieben. So in der Formulierung
geht das vielleicht sogar noch ganz gut,
wobei man ehrlich sagen muss,
dass ich schon ziemlich harte Formulierungen
für eine Stellenanzeige, ja.
Ja, viel besser.
Einfach umschreiben,
denn der Witz war ja, wir mussten
Chat-GPT erstmal dazu überreden, das
überhaupt zu hart zu formulieren.
MWD fehlt, stimmt,
natürlich.
Okay.
Für US-Stellenausschreibungen
ist das okay.
Ja gut, US-Stellenausschreibungen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob,
was die da für Anforderungen haben,
aber da sind sie generell ein bisschen
härter drauf, zumindest dann im Umgang mit
den Leuten auch. So nach dem Motto, wie.
Du hast das
nicht gemacht, instant
gefeuert, weg, next.
Okay,
so, schauen wir mal.
Was gibt es denn hier auf YouTube
für tolle Sachen?
Falls es überhaupt irgendwas gibt.
Fake.
Desktour, nope, brauche ich nicht,
juckt mich nicht.
Alles geht in den Bach runter.
Ja, Ring, es gab irgendwie
Zugriff bei Amazon auf Ring-Kameras
und solche Geschichten habe ich letztens
gelesen. Und
ich glaube,
habe ich letztens gelesen.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema sehen, dass es eine blöde Idee
ist, Kameras
mit Cloud-Anbindung.
Lebenslauf
für IT-Professionals.
Da bin ich gespannt, was er dazu sagt,
weil ich wollte ja auch ein Video machen, wo ich euch
meine Bewerbung, Lebenslauf und Skill-Liste
zeige.
Müsste ich eigentlich
jetzt noch machen,
denn am dritten fange ich ja an.
Das ist dann auch blöd, wenn ich das erst zeige, nachdem ich angefangen habe,
oder?
Außerdem wird es immer wieder Zeit
für ein neues Video.
Das ändert
nochmal alles. Chat-GPT-4 ausprobiert.
Okay, komm, wir haben jetzt
selbst ein bisschen AI gebastelt.
Wir
gucken wir uns jetzt 14
Minuten, das kann man sich nochmal schnell geben. Dann ist aber genug
AI heute für den Stream.
Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht.
Oder hier, das finde ich noch krasser.
Erklär dieses Meme hier.
Manchmal gucke ich mir Bilder von der Erde an
und staune darüber, wie wunderschön alles
ist. Ja, und da sagt GPT-4,
das Meme kombiniert zwar eigentlich nicht
zusammengehörige Dinge, nämlich Bilder von der Erde
aus dem All und Chicken Nuggets.
Wow. Nur nochmal zur Sicherheit, damit
das allen klar ist. GPT-4 ist eine
Software, kein Mensch. Oder hier,
eine Prüfungsfrage der französischen
Ecole Polytechnique, einfach so als
Bild draufgeworfen und gesagt, bitte
Schritt für Schritt Frage römisch 1
1 a beantworten. Zack, richtig
beantwortet.
Und jetzt nochmal so richtig
wow. Wow.
Ein auf ein Blatt Papier gekritzelte Skizze
von einer Webseite. Meine Witz Webseite
hier ein lustiger Joke. Und wenn ich draufklick
soll die Perlente kommen. Ja, und dann gibt
GPT-4 halt den Code für die Webseite
aus. Okay. Wow.
Wow. Aber um die Begeisterung
mal ein bisschen abzumildern, all diese
vier Beispiele haben wir nicht selbst ausprobieren
können, sondern kommen von OpenAI
den Entwicklern von GPT-4.
Also auf die sogenannten multimodalen
Funktionen, also dass man GPT-4 mit Bildern
füttern kann, zum Beispiel darauf haben bislang erst
ein paar Leute Zugriff. Das ist noch nicht veröffentlicht.
Aber die reinen Textfunktionen
von GPT-4, die konnten wir schon
ausprobieren. Die sind nämlich schon Teil
vom kostenpflichtigen Chat-GPT.
Und das ist auch sehr beeindruckend und deutlich.
Was kosten das eigentlich? Was kosten eigentlich?
Das gucken wir jetzt mal schnell. Pricing.
Warum mache ich da eigentlich meine VM dazu an?
20 Euro im Monat? Okay.
Upgrade
Chat-GPT-Pricing.
Upgrade Chat-GPT-Pricing.
Ne, nicht Upgrade Chat-GPT-Pricing. Pro.
Pro Tokens?
GPT-Pri- Also hier, das da.
Ah, 20 Euro.
20 Dollar im Monat.
Okay.
Ja.
Wenn man das oft benutzt, ist das sicherlich gut
investierte Kohle.
Wow.
Sehr lustige Fehler haben wir aber dennoch gefunden.
Bleibt dran.
Liebe Hackerinnen, lieber Internetserver,
herzlich willkommen hierbei.
Wow.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert
von Only Office.
Okay, es ist wenigstens Only Office.
Hast du Office Suite einen Plug-In veröffentlicht
mit dem Chat-GPT? Ne.
Ja, sind wir denn jetzt GPT
3003 oder was?
Es gibt ja nur noch Videos zu diesem KI-Kram
hier, Menno. Ja, YouTube ist voll damit.
Eigentlich wäre heute was anderes dran gewesen,
aber da ist diese Woche halt
GPT-4 angekündigt worden.
Ich hab etliche Nachrichten von euch
da draußen bekommen, dass wir darüber doch
bitte was machen sollen. Und ja,
da sind wir doch jetzt wieder mit KI, weil
das ist einfach nicht so einfach.
Ja.
EPI ist AI.
Ist schon durch. Das haben wir schon gemacht.
Schon eine große Sache. Aber
was ist eigentlich GPT? Ist das nicht
das gleiche wie Chat-GPT. Nein.
GPT ist ein KI
Textgenerator von der US-firma
OpenAI. Die Abkürzung ist
entlang Generative Pre-Trained
transformer. Und das Ganze
dient als Motor etlicher
KI-Produkte. Ein eigenes User-Unterface
hat das GPT nicht, sondern lässt
sich nur über eine Programmierschnittstelle
der API anzapfen. Und damit können Firmen
dann Produkte bauen. Wenn sie
denn pro 1000 Token, das
entspricht vier Buchstaben, ein paar...
Wohlgemerkt in dem...
Ach nee.
Ist jetzt getrennt
Prompt-Tokens und Anfrage-Tokens.
Weil bei der letzten
API-Version, wo ich geguckt hab, war das
Prompt und
das, was man wissen wollte, war das noch in einem.
Das heißt, der Prompt zählte mit...
...was es
nicht teuer gemacht hat.
Aha.
Und Token sind ja wie gesagt vier
Buchstaben ungefähr. Also wären das ca.
24.000 Wörter. Zum Vergleich,
der gesprochene Text in diesem Video sind
ungefähr 2.000 Wörter. Franz
Kafka's, die Verwandlung, etwas über
19.000 Wörter. GPT-4
kann also theoretisch Bücher schreiben.
Bei GPT-3 waren das nur ungefähr
3.000 Wörter. Und klar kann man
sich dann halt auch ein Buch basteln...
Und chat.gpt
hat schon
sehr viel geschwafelt, ja.
Bisher.
Ja.
Yo, yo, was geht
ab?
ab, Leute?
Yo, yo, was geht
Da fehlen noch die Bitches.
Cringe.
Oh ne, please,
nein, nein, nein.
Nein, Hilfe,
please, please.
Oh ne, hör mal auf.
Cringe time.
Okay, okay, es
geht nicht lange.
Also, wirklich ganz klar, GPT-4
ist kreativer. Das neue Bing
von Microsoft nutzt übrigens auch
schon GPT-4. Das durfte Microsoft
offenbar jetzt erst öffentlich sagen.
Und da hatten wir im Video ja auch schon festgestellt,
dass zum Beispiel die Witze deutlich besser
sind als bei dem alten Chat-GPT-Modell.
Was haben Jan Kino-Jansen
und Apache207 gemeinsam?
Sie sind beide Experten für
Strom. Der eine schreibt über
Balkonkraftwerke, der andere rappt über
Blitze. Und
persönlicher GPT-4 bei mir Ehensteine
Brett, weil es mich endlich
korrekt beschreibt. Bei GPT-3-5
war wirklich alles falsch, wenn man gefragt
hat, wer ich bin, inklusive ausgewürfelten
Geburtsdatum und irgendwelchen ausgedachten
Büchern. Wenn ich GPT-4 allerdings
konkret nach Büchern frage, die ich geschrieben
haben soll, dann halluciniert ist auch wieder Quatsch.
Besonders krass ist der Quatsch
allerdings, wenn man Chat-GPT
für Sachtexte nutzen will.
Also journalistische Texte oder sogar
wissenschaftliche. Ja, das ist tatsächlich echt
ein Problem. Das liest sich immer alles
so aus einem Guss und Schlüssig.
Aber da steht halt oftmals Blödsinn
drin. Ich hab das schon oft gemerkt, wenn man
nach irgendwelchen Kommandozeilenbefehlen
fragt und sich das dann ein bisschen genauer
erklären lässt, da kommen dann ganz
wirre, wirre
Geschichten.
So nach dem Motto
Ersync
wird benutzt, um Dateien
zu kopieren,
indem es die Festplatte
formatiert. Hab ich mir jetzt ausgedacht.
Aber so ganz komische
zusammen,
die nicht zusammen passen
kommen da drin. Jemand, der keine Ahnung hat, wissen
wird das wahrscheinlich nicht erkennen.
Auch wenn
Wissenschaftsverlage das
Arbeiten mit Chat-GPT, sagen wir mal,
zumindest kritisch sehen, wird sich das in Zukunft
ja vielleicht mal ändern. Ganz ordentlich
funktioniert das jedenfalls mit so Themen, die schon
omnipräsent sind im Internet.
Wenn ich Chat-GPT zum Beispiel darum bitte, dass es mir
einen Wissenschaftlichen Aufsatz über die Markteinführung
des iPhones schreibt, dann funktioniert das
gut. Wir haben in unserem Test festgestellt,
dass die Art und Weise, wie Chat-GPT sich
jetzt ausdrückt, wirklich deutlich besser ist.
Ich hab mir wirklich oft gedacht, hätte ich auch
nicht schöner schreiben können. Gerade beim
wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten ist das Angeben
von Quellen super wichtig.
Und damit hatte Chat-GPT in der Vergangenheit
seine Problemchen. Bei unserem iPhone
Beispiel hier macht Chat-GPT einen
echt guten Job und sucht passende Quellen raus,
die man auch so in der wissenschaftlichen Arbeit
angeben könnte. Problematisch wird es aber,
wenn man Chat-GPT bittet, einen wissenschaftlichen
Text über ein unbekannteres Thema zu schreiben.
Wenn ich hier zum Beispiel eine wissenschaftliche Arbeit
über den deutschen Kameramann Gernot
Roll schreiben möchte, kommt Chat-GPT 4
immer noch ganz schön, entschwitzen. Der Text,
den mir die neue Version von Chat-GPT liefert,
ist zwar viel besser als vorher, aber leider
noch immer... Ich finde es auch nicht sinnvoll,
Chat-GPT zu verbieten für
Hausarbeiten, weil das Problem
ist, die Leute können es ja
trotzdem benutzen. Und dann müsstest du ihnen
irgendwie beweisen, dass es aus Chat-GPT
ist. Und was machst du denn, wenn der Chat
einfach nur so aussieht, wenn der
Ergebnis einfach nur so aussieht wie Chat-GPT
und es ist gar nicht Chat-GPT. Ich finde das nicht schlimm,
Hausaufgaben
mit
Chat-GPT zu machen. Du musst
den Leuten halt erzählen, dass sie dafür
verantwortlich sind, was sie abgeben. Und wenn
Chat-GPT irgendeinen Mist reinschreibt, dann sind
sie halt dafür verantwortlich, dass da Mist drinne steht
und dann gibt es halt Punktabzug. Ganz einfach.
Und naja,
sie müssen sich ja trotzdem mit dem Thema
auseinandersetzen, wenn sie wissen wollen,
ob das stimmt, was da drin steht.
Das ist gar nicht so verkehrt.
Also ich finde,
der ist ein Verbot von Chat-GPT in der Schule
ist realitätsfern, weil
man es trotzdem
machen kann.
Und du schaffst dir,
glaube ich, wenn du das verbietest, nur noch
viel mehr Probleme.
Und die Firma, an denen Gernot Roll
mitgewirkt haben soll, stimmen in einigen
Fällen einfach nicht. Und das Buch,
das mir Chat-GPT als Quelle dafür angehebt,
existiert nicht mal. Aber wenigstens
nimmt Chat-GPT meine Korrekturvorschläge
freundlicher auf als Bing.
Aber genau diese Ungenauigkeiten
haben System. Die Sprachmodelle
wollen mir so dringend Antworten liefern,
dass es sich zur Not einfach welche ausdenkt.
Das wird auch deutlich, wenn ich mir hier mal was
über die neueste Apple Watch Ultra
schreiben lassen möchte. Denn auch wenn Chat-GPT
immer wieder darauf hinweist, dass es nur Information
bis zum September 2021
hat, wenn man es aber darum bittet,
ein Artikel über ein Produkt zu schreiben, das erst danach
auf den Markt gekommen ist, macht es das in den
meisten Fällen trotzdem. Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel
einen Text über die Apple Watch Ultra haben möchte,
erfindet Chat-GPT einfach irgendwelche
Fakten und zeigt mir den gleichen Text,
wie wenn ich nach der Apple Watch Mega
3003 frage. GPT-4
ist also in vielen Sachen schon echt gut,
aber erfindet eben Dinge.
Das gibt OpenAI übrigens auch offen
zu. Auf der Website steht schwarz auf
weiß. Am wichtigsten ist GPT-4
ist noch nicht vollständig
zuverlässig. Es halluciniert Fakten
und macht Denkfehler. In den meisten
Reichen liegt die Genauigkeit laut
OpenAI noch unter 80%.
Das heißt also, bei 80%
der Antworten würden Menschen mit Expertise
in diesem Bereich sagen, alles
korrekt. Bei 20% der Antworten gibt es
aber keinen Fehler. Das ist zumindest laut
OpenAI schon deutlich besser als
bei den älteren Modellen. Ganz interessant
übrigens, es gibt schon etablierte Benchmarks,
mit denen man solche Sprachmodelle testen
kann. Zum Teil sind das speziell auf
Sprachmodelle ausgelegt.
Das nächste, was dann kommt, ist
explizit auf diese Benchmarks
trainierte Modelle.
So wie beim Browser JavaScript,
ne ne, nicht beim Browser,
bei Web Framework Benchmark.
So nach dem Motto, wir geben einfach statisches
HTML zurück und sind dann schnell
im Benchmark.
Mit denen man solche Sprachmodelle testen kann.
Zum Teil sind das speziell auf Sprachmodelle
ausgelegte Tests, zum Teil aber auch
standardisierte Prüfungen, wie das
juristische Barrexam aus den USA.
Und laut OpenAI, das muss man immer
dazu sagen, deklassiert
GPT-4 die gesamte Konkurrenz
bei diesen Tests. Aber das muss man
halt auch sagen, ist GPT-4 halt komplett
close source und kommerziell.
Was das heißt, das merkt man ja jetzt schon.
Zugriff über ChatGPT bekommen nur
Leute, die umgerechnet 23 Euro
im Monat für ChatGPT Plus bezahlen.
Und das ist dann
womöglich die Zukunft. Wer tolle
Sachen mit KI machen will und damit
vielleicht sogar bessere Chancen in Schule
und Beruf hat, ja, das geht eben nur für
Leute, die das bezahlen können. Also Leute,
die sowieso schon bessere Chancen haben.
Ich hoffe, dass da in Zukunft
Open Source Alternativen entstehen,
nur ist es zur Zeit noch sehr teuer, diese
Sprachmodelle zu trainieren. Aber zum
Beispiel hat Meta neulich erst Lama
veröffentlicht, ein Sprachmodell, das durchaus
mit GPT mithalten kann und so
halb Open Source ist, auf das
Forschungseinrichtungen Zugriff
beantragen können. Ja, und die benötigten
Daten, übrigens 219
Gigabyte, hä, wo weiß ich das eigentlich,
sind längst als Torrent in
der Welt. Hab ich zumindest gehört.
Und was immer krasses passiert, wenn man
Sachen in die Welt entlässt, Leute
machen crazy Sachen damit, mit denen die
ursprünglichen Macher gar nicht gedacht haben,
zum Beispiel das Lama-Sprachmodell auf einem
Raspi laufen zu lassen. Obwohl
das eigentlich für irgendwelche NVIDIA
A100-Karten konzipiert ist,
die 5-stellig kosten. Interessiert euch
das womöglich, also die ganze Hardware-Seite
dieser KI-Systeme, sollen wir dazu
mal ein Video machen. Es ist halt wahrscheinlich langsam als
Fuck auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Ich hab letztens irgendwo was drüber gelesen,
dass ein,
ich krieg's nicht mehr zusammen,
also der
Chat-GPT-Cluster, da besteht
ja aus, was weiß ich,
250 Nodes,
mit, ähm,
lief das nicht sogar auf
Apple?
Arm-Hardware?
Das war,
das war auf jeden Fall ordentlich, ordentlich fette
Hardware drin. Ihr wisst schon.
Mein Fazit zu GPT-4.
Es ist wirklich so beeindruckend,
wie schnell... Oh, ein Super Nintendo-Controller
in der Hand. Warum
hat er eben einfach einen Super Nintendo-Controller in der Hand?
...nochmal mal gemerkt hat, dass sie einfach
nur so ein stochastischer Papagei-
Wort-Wahrscheinlichkeiten ausrechnen.
Da hat man hier wirklich schon sehr häufig das Gefühl,
dass man mit menschlicher Intelligenz
interagiert. Und dass das System jetzt
auch noch sehen kann und das, was es sieht,
verstehen. Das ist wirklich ein Schritt
Richtung AGI, also
Artificial General Intelligence, künstliche
Allgemeine Intelligenz, also
echte Intelligenz. Ich sage euch, Leute,
diese Technik wird sehr viel
verändern auf der Welt und ich hoffe
wirklich nur zum Guten. Tschüss.
Natürlich, so wie jede Technik immer nur
zum Guten benutzt wurde.
Bonus-Gag, okay. Cringe-Time.
Ja, und da wir natürlich alle
Tex-KIs mit einem Witz testen,
in dem Martin Luther einen Schokoladenkuchen
und Raspberry Pi drin vorkommen muss,
testen, haben wir GPT-4
natürlich auch nach einem solchen Witz gefragt.
Und der geht so.
Eines Tages beschloss Martin
Luther ein bisschen Spaß zu haben
und lud einen Raspberry Pi und einen Schokoladenkuchen
zu einem Wettstreit ein.
Wer von ihnen könne die meisten seiner
95 Thesen verstehen? Zuerst
versuchte der Schokoladenkuchen doch jedes Mal,
wenn er etwas sagen wollte, brach er einfach in Stücke.
Der Kuchen war lecker, aber
definitiv nicht der beste Gesprächspartner.
Dann war der Raspberry Pi an der Reihe.
Nachdem er alle 95 Thesen
gelesen hatte, gab er seine Antwort,
ich habe zwar keine Reformation im Sinn, aber
ich kann alle 95 Thesen in 95
Sekunden herunterladen und in einem 3D-
Modell von Wittenberg visualisieren.
Martin Luther war beeindruckt, doch bevor er
den Sieger verkünden konnte, tauchte ein
hungriger Mönch auf und aß den Schokoladenkuchen auf.
In diesem Moment erklärte der
Raspberry Pi, ich sehe, der Mönch
hat die süße Verlockung der Sünde gewählt.
Lass mich dir helfen Martin, eine neue
Thesenliste zu erstellen, die 95
lecker bist in der Reformation.
Was?
Und so begann eine unerwartete
Freundschaft zwischen Martin Luther und dem
Raspberry Pi, die schließlich zur Gründung
des ersten himmlischen Computer Clubs
führte, dessen erster Punkt auf der Tagesordnung
war, wie man göttlichen Schokoladenkuchen
backt, ohne die Thesen zu verlieren.
Was auch immer.
Alles klar.
Ja, chat, bitte neigt
ja ordentlich zum Labern.
Das ist ja nichts Neues.
Immer noch weniger
Cringe als TikTok. Das stimmt,
aber es ist fast alles weniger Cringe als
TikTok.
Jetzt können wir uns ja erst mal angucken.
Ich bin schon immer wieder mit
Recruitern.
Wir gucken uns mal an,
wie man eine Bewerbung als
IT-Experte
Professional schreibt.
Was witzig ist,
sogar hier im Stream waren ja schon Leute, die gefragt
haben, Max, hast du Tipps für die
Stellenanzeige von unserem Unternehmen?
Und da haben wir uns hier Stellenanzeige zusammen angeguckt.
Finde ich eigentlich cool,
ja.
Tatsächlich hat sich in den letzten
Jahren da einiges verändert.
Und gerade in der Informatik ist ein
völlig anderer Punkt in den Vordergrund gerückt.
Ich versuche euch meine neuen
Tipps zu geben, die ich aus dieser Perspektive
geben kann.
Stellt es euch so vor, Firmen bekommen für eine
Stelle, wenn es denn eine wirklich geile
Stelle ist, gut und gerne mal 200
Bewerbung, eher mehr. Aber
wenn es eine wirklich geile Stelle ist, das stimmt
schon. Man muss halt sagen,
die meisten Stellen sind nicht geil und bekommen
aktuell eher gar keine Bewerbung.
Oder vielleicht sind die Stellen geil
und die Stellenausschreibungen sind einfach
nur mega kacke.
Ich könnte empfehlen, Chat-GPT zu fragen
und zwar erstmal Windows beleidigen
und
dann auch schreiben,
dass man jeden Niedungsbefehl wie einen Boss
beherrscht. Das ist immer eine gute, gute Sache.
Wo ist denn da der Fachkräftemangel,
sagt ihr vielleicht. Tja, liebe Firmen,
das ist ein ganz anderes Thema.
Aber mal ernsthaft, bei 200 Bewerbung...
Wisst ihr was? Wisst ihr was wir jetzt noch schnell probieren?
Wisst ihr was wir jetzt noch schnell probieren?
Der soll eine Bewerbung schreiben?
Wie?
Alter, ich fasse es nicht.
Hat mich das schon wieder ausgelockt. Warum?
Es hat mich schon wieder ausgelockt.
WTF? Ist das gerade wieder am abspacken oder wie?
Da hat wieder zu viel drinne oder was?
Chat Open AI. Ich lock mich gleich ein, Leute.
Es eselt gleich wieder was.
Okay.
Okay, nice. Da sind wir wieder eingelockt.
Jaja, next, next, done.
Okay.
Wo haben wir denn Text hier?
Schreibe mir eine Bewerbung für folgende Stellenanzeige.
Sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, okay, geht schon gut los.
Okay, als begeisterter Linux-Enthusiast und Experte für Cloud-Technologien habe ich mit großem Interesse Ihre Stellanzeige für einen Senior-Linux-Engineer gelesen.
Ihre Beschreibung nach einem Linux-Guru, der jeden Befehl basht in die Cloud wie seine Rückanzahl, spricht mich besonders an.
Entschuldigung. Ich verfüge über mehrere Jahre Erfahrung in der Entwicklung von Linux-basierten Lösungen sowie der Verwaltung.
Agilität ist für mich sondern ein integraler Bestandteil meiner Arbeitsweise.
Ich bin motiviert und gemeinsam auch die bereitstellten Schichtarbeiten überschützt.
Das heißt für mich selbstverständlich, alles klar.
Ich bin bereit, mich voll und ganz für die Erreichung unserer Ziele einzusetzen, aber auch persönliche Opfer zu bringen.
Alter, im Leben, im Leben nicht, würde ich das so, na egal.
Ich freue mich darauf, dass er...
Schreibe die Bewerbung mehr hip. Schreibe die Bewerbung hipper.
Yo Leute.
Beste Ansprache.
Beste Ansprache für eine Bewerbung aller Zeiten.
Yo Leute.
Yo, was geht?
Ihr sucht einen absolut genialen Senior Linux-Engineer, der Windows als das Scheißsystem betrachtet, das es ist.
Dann seid ihr bei mir genau richtig.
Ich bin ein waschechter Linux-Guru, der jeden Befehl wie ein Boss beherrscht und der wiederholt einfach nur die Stellenanzeige.
Und die Cloud wie seine Westentasche kennt.
Kubernetes und NoSQL sind für mich keine Skills, die ich wie meine eigene Mutter sprach.
Kein Problem für mich.
Ich bin der agile Boss.
Ich bin der agile Boss, der das alles im Griff hat.
Aber hey, lasst euch von dieser bescheidenen Stellenbeschreibung nicht...
Moment, das ist verkehrt drum. Egal.
Wir alle wissen, dass das alles in der Hand ist.
Aber hey, lasst euch von dieser bescheidenen Stellenbeschreibung nicht...
Moment, das ist verkehrt drum. Egal.
Wir alle wissen, dass ihr einen echten Hero sucht, der bereit ist, 24-7 zu arbeiten und alle Verpflichtungen zu vergessen, um die besten Ergebnisse zu liefern.
Das ist genau das, was ich spiele.
Egal, ob es um meine Familie, meine Freunde, meine Hobbys geht.
Wenn es darum geht, Linux zu rocken, habe ich nur Augen dafür.
Ich bin bereit, alles zu geben und gemeinsam mit meinem Team unschlagbare Lösungen zu entwickeln.
Ich bin ein motivierter Leader, der Verantwortung übernimmt und Entscheidungen mit dem, was bestmöglich ist.
Lasst mich euer neuer Senior-Linux-Engineer sein.
Ich werde dafür sorgen, dass euer Unternehmen durch die Decke geht.
Ich kann jetzt kaum erwarten, meine Fähigkeiten und meine Energien...
Stay cool.
Okay, das ist mega hip. Alles klar.
Der agile Boss.
Nice, sehr schön.
Würde ich sofort einstellen.
Ist instant eingestellt.
Vor allem, weil er Windows als das Scheißsystem betrachtet, das es ist.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir uns die Stellanzeigen an.
Es ist etwas schwierig, wirklich jeden Menschen hinter dem Lebenslauf kennenzulernen.
Und hier kommt ihr ins Spiel.
Die meisten interessieren sich doch nicht für den Menschen hinter dem Lebenslauf.
Die wollen irgendjemanden haben, der auf die Stelle passt, gute Arbeit liefert und umgänglich ist.
Ansonsten...
...wird mir das auch egal.
...Herausstechen und euch beweisen, ohne dass ihr die Möglichkeit habt, auch nur ein Wort zu sagen.
Und leider auch oftmals ohne, dass euer Lebenslauf wirklich komplett gelesen wird.
Ja, das ist normal.
An der Stelle ein kurzer Shoutout an meinen Kollegen, Niklas Steenfart.
Er hat seinen Lebenslauf für die Facebook Bewerbung in einem Video geteilt.
Und deswegen gehe ich hier über diese Tipps, nur ganz kurz drüber.
Viel wichtiger ist doch die Frage, was ist denn eigentlich so anders?
Manche Firmen werden überrannt mit Jobangeboten, andere gehen komplett leer aus.
Andere nicht, weil die Stellanzeige kacke ist oder sie bekannt dafür sind, nichts zu bezahlen oder was auch immer.
Man spricht von einem Fachkräftemangel, allerdings gibt es auch immer mehr, die in den Beruf quer einsteigen.
Auch Informatik wird mehr und mehr zum Quer-Einsteigerfeld.
Es gibt Trainings, Bootcamps und das wissen natürlich auch viele Firmen.
Hier ein wichtiger Tipp.
Bewerbt ihr euch bei einer wirklich begehrten oder großen Firma, müsst ihr euch gegen viele Mitbewerber behaupten.
Mehrere Interviews, auch technischer Natur, sind da völlig normal.
Oder man hat das Glück und kennt schon jemand, der dort arbeitet und wird gefragt, ob man nicht zu ihm kommen will.
Ich meine, das ist natürlich enormer Luxus.
Aber ansonsten hätte ich wahrscheinlich gar keinen neuen Job gesucht.
Weil ihr wisst, wie faul ich bin.
Hätten die Leute mich nicht gefragt, hätte ich wahrscheinlich gar keine Bewerbung geschrieben.
Geht man aber zu einer kleinen Firma, klappt es oft sehr viel leichter und das kann man als Sprung prägnen.
Warum das hilfreich ist, erfahrt ihr gleich.
Zuerst aber das Layout.
Hier gilt das KISS-Prinzip.
Das kennt ihr vielleicht aus der Softwareentwicklung.
Allerhöchstens zwei Seiten.
Besser ist eigentlich sogar eine Seite.
Und ich beispielsweise scanne als ...
Ich hab tatsächlich auch nur eine Seite.
Kurz drüber.
Und manchmal wird die zweite Seite dabei gar nicht mehr angesehen.
Ich hab auch nur eine Seite.
Der erste Eindruck ist also wahnsinnig entscheidend.
Eine Seite und hinten dran als Anhang noch Skill-Liste.
Das sind dann drei Seiten.
Aber das muss ja nicht unbedingt in den Lebenslauf.
What the fuck?
Ich hatte schwarz-weiß, blau.
Ich hatte ein bisschen blau im Lebenslauf noch.
Das ist auch ein bisschen schwarz-weiß, blau.
Ja, mein Foto ist drin.
Das fände ich cool zum Beispiel.
Kommt drauf an, wo man landet.
Es kommt halt auf den Laden an.
Das ist eigentlich das Wichtigste.
Es muss letztendlich zu dem Unternehmen passen.
Wenn das irgendwie so junges, hippes Start-up ist
Wir hatten doch letztendlich die PHP-Piraten.
Hier.
Die hätten...
Fuck, Alter.
Moment, das ist was anderes.
Das ist was anderes hier.
Wir hatten doch letztendlich die Typen hier.
Wo wir uns das auch angeguckt haben.
Die fänden das bestimmt lustig, wenn man sich da mit einem Piraten-Meme bewirbt.
Auch wenn es für nur ein Projekt ist.
Das Foto selbst hingegen ist ein kleiner Streitpunkt.
Beziehungsweise eigentlich kulturartig.
Mein Foto sieht so kacke aus.
Für eine Bewerbung in Europa, also vor allem auch...
Ich kann es euch leider jetzt nicht zeigen.
Deutschland, Schweiz und Österreich gehört eigentlich fast immer ein Foto auf den Lebenslauf.
Lustigerweise darf in Deutschland nicht explizit nach einem Foto gefragt werden.
Wegen Datenschutz.
Aber erwartet wird es.
Und unter Umständen wird eure Bewerbung völlig ignoriert, wenn das Foto nicht drauf ist.
Hingegen in den USA, Kanada und Großbritannien solltet ihr kein Foto mit schicken.
Besonders bei akademischen Berufen oder Führungspositionen.
Aha.
Wer natürlich dabei steht, bitte schicken sie ihre Bewerbungsunterlagen ohne Foto.
Dann macht ihr natürlich auch in Deutschland kein Foto drauf.
Wichtig ist aber auch die Reihenfolge der Fähigkeiten.
Zuerst die Berufserfahrung, dann die Ausbildung, dann der Rest.
In manchen Fällen darf sogar vor der Berufserfahrung noch ein Satz.
So habe ich es auch gemacht.
Weil ich...
Ich habe mir keine Tutorials durchgelesen oder sowas.
Ich habe mir einfach überlegt, ey, was interessiert die denn, ob ich gut in der Schule war oder so.
Oder was ich in der Schule, wie sie in der Schule war.
Ich habe auch angefangen rückwirkend so mit dem Aktuellen zum Alten.
Also von aktuell zu...
Und ich habe nicht angefangen mit schulischer Ausbildung und Zeug.
Das interessiert doch kein Mensch.
Ja.
Wie gesagt, ich würde euch meinen Lebenslauf zeigen.
Ich kann ihn euch nicht zeigen.
Da stehen zu viele persönliche Sachen drin.
Ich musste ihn aber eh fürs Video ein bisschen abändern und aufhübschen.
Also nicht aufhübschen.
Aufhübschen ist das falsche Wort.
Abändern und vielleicht schwärzen, dass man manche Sachen nicht sieht.
Ja.
Soll ich euch sagen?
Ich kann euch sagen, was ich meine.
Ich sage euch was.
Ich kann es euch nicht zeigen.
Ich kann euch aber sagen, was ich da drin stehen, was ich da drin stehen habe bei mir.
Ich lese euch mal kurz vor.
Also es fängt bei mir an mit beruflicher Erfahrung.
Also links ist ein Foto mit Name.
Unten drunter steht Geburts, also Alter, Geburtstag, Geburtsort, Staatsangehörigkeit, Adresse, Telefonnummer, E-Mail-Adresse.
Steht so auf der linken Seite.
So.
Und rechts steht quasi die Sachen, die interessant sind.
Und zwar fängt es an mit beruflicher Erfahrung.
Dann steht dann da DevOps Engineer, Blablabla, Dienstleister, Blablabla, meine Aufgaben waren
Umsetzung und Etablierung eines Infrastructure as Code Release Management für 3000 Linux
Systemen mit Hilfe von Git, Puppet, Ansible, Terraform und Formen.
Steht da drin.
Da steht Linux System Engineer, Red Hat, Ubuntu, Hochverfügbarkeit, Ausfallsicherheit, Security,
Containerisierung und Skalierung, Toolentwicklung C-Sharp, .NET 6, Go, JavaScript, Ruby, Konzeption
und Durchführung, neue technische Dokumentation, Linux System inklusive automatischen Datenimport.
Dann geht es weiter zum nächsten Job.
Blablabla, Blablabla, bei Blablabla.
Meine Aufgaben waren Administration eines komplexen 24-7-Systems auf Red Hat Basis, System und
Infrastruktur Monitoring, Prometheus, Zappix, Nagios, Wartung, Austausch von Server Software.
So, dann geht es jetzt zurück zu meiner ersten Firma, wo ich gewesen bin, beim Provider.
Server Administrator bei Blablabla.
Übrigens, ich habe letztens gelesen, der Provider, bei dem ich ursprünglich meine
Ausbildung gemacht habe und meine ersten Berufsjahre verbracht habe, ist mittlerweile Pleite.
Den gönne ich auch, dass sie Pleite sind, richtiger Kackladen gewesen.
So, da habe ich auch geschrieben, Administration, System, Red Hat Basis, Inbetriebnahme, Wartung,
Cisco Netzwerke, Aufbau, Enterprise, Nagios, Monitoring System.
Und dann geht es unten drunter weiter mit Ausbildung und dann mit der Schule.
Und ganz unten drunter habe ich tatsächlich noch weiteres, habe ich noch hinzugeschrieben,
seit 2012 nebenberufliche Webvideoproduzent.
Ich dachte, man kann es ja mal erwähnen, dass ich YouTube-Stells mache.
Und dann habe ich noch mein GitHub-Profil reingeschrieben, mehrere Open Source-Projekte
auf GitHub, zum Beispiel Blablabla.
Und habe mein GitHub-Repo noch dabei gehauen.
Das ist übrigens auch der Grund, warum ich...
Der Fiat Champ steht da natürlich auch drin.
Das ist übrigens auch der Grund, warum ich mein GitHub-Profil jetzt neuerdings pinned
Repos habe.
Ich habe nur die Dinger, die man sich halbwegs angucken kann, oben hingepinned.
Nicht den ganzen anderen Shit, man.
What the?
Warum bin ich die letzten Tage so aktiv?
100, 205 Contributions am Sonntag.
Alles klar.
Ah, das war unser Copernetis-Stells, wo ich alle 20 Sekunden gepusht habe.
Sehr realistisch, 205 Contributions.
Das ist das agile, aktive High-Performer-Diagonal-Skalierer-Mindset.
Ja.
Okay, weiter.
Das stimmt wohl.
Das ist Werbung.
Wer muss sagen...
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall was dran.
Wobei ich sagen muss, da sind sie fast ein bisschen überpingelig.
Auf der anderen Seite kann man schon erwarten, wenn man eine Bewerbung schreibt, dass man
sich Mühe gibt, das nochmal Probe liest und sowas in der Richtung.
Aber je nachdem, wie man das geschrieben hat, ist ja manches nicht so, ja, hundertprozentig
klar, gerade manchmal Kommersetzung oder sowas.
Wenn da mal ein Fehler ist, okay, dann hättet ihr bei mir wahrscheinlich auch keine Probleme.
Aber es gibt sicherlich Leute, die sind dann super oberkorrekt und pingelig, ja.
Ah, okay, noch Werbung.
Tatsächlich, mein Lebenslauf sieht ein bisschen so aus, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen
so.
Aber ich sag mal so, Personality steht da nicht unten drunter, Languages steht da auch
nicht unten drunter.
Also das da steht da nicht, aber so ungefähr.
Der klassische Lebenslauf, in diesem Fall übrigens viel zu leer, der Platz darf gerne
genutzt werden.
Dann der moderne Lebenslauf für meinen Geschmack mit ein bisschen zu viel Farbe und die Kenntnisse
in Greisen zu gestalten ist gewöhnungsbedürftig, aber man kann das durchaus machen.
Anschließend haben wir sogar noch den kreativen Lebenslauf.
Boah, Pfeilfeder.
Den würde ich, okay, da hätte ich das Problem, das würde ich noch nicht mal checken, wenn
ich es lesen müsste als Recruiter.
Was will die mir überhaupt sagen?
Wobei ich wahrscheinlich nicht im passenden Management-Mindset bin, um das zu checken.
Ja, genau.
Ich check's auch nicht.
Da kommen wir übrigens zum nächsten Punkt.
Jeder Lebenslauf muss an den Job angepasst sein, auf den ihr euch bewerbt.
Bewerbt ihr euch als Frontend-Designer.
Modern CV...
Sag ich mal ja.
Äh, gibt's da vielleicht auch ein Bild von?
Ne.
Der wird ein bisschen besonderer und spannender sein.
Bewerbt ihr euch hingegen als Data-Scientist oder Cybersecurity-Analyst.
Macht es wenig Sinn, eure künstlerischen Fähigkeiten unter Beweis zu stellen.
Dann darf es auch gerne ein wenig schlichter sein.
Vielleicht sogar einen ganz klassischen Lebenslauf.
Das heißt nicht, dass ihr gar keine modernen Elemente nutzen dürft.
Aber vielleicht tendenziell eher weniger.
Es ist ohnehin eine sehr individuelle Frage, ob ein Recruiter ein...
Ich bin immer noch der Meinung, man muss selbst hinter dem Lebenslauf stehen und damit zufrieden sein.
Es muss zu einem passen.
Ja, natürlich, es muss auch zur Stelle passen.
Das ist auch wichtig.
Aber es muss irgendwie, es muss zu einem passen.
Man muss ein gutes Gefühl haben beim Schreiben und beim Abschicken.
Layout mag oder nicht.
Ich mag den kreativen Lebenslauf einfach gar nicht.
Ich auch nicht.
Ich würde mit dem modernen, einem klassischen Lebenslauf immer vorziehen.
Ja.
Vielleicht weil mich das Design...
Sieht optisch.
... am Pen and Paper erinnert.
Weiß ich nicht.
Solltet ihr das Privileg haben zu wissen, wer euer Recruiter ist, könnt ihr da ein bisschen tricksen.
Hier kommen jetzt also die Geheimtipps.
Falscher-Time.
Meist gehen die Namen dabei, wo ihr die Bewerbung hinschicken müsst.
Erstmal Stalken.
Ihr dürft durchaus den Namen des Recruiters...
... auf LinkedIn oder Social Media suchen, um ihn einschätzen zu können.
Eher klassisch unterwegs...
Blöd ist nur, wenn man den Recruiter dann das Only-Fans-Profil findet.
... im Anzug oder vielleicht doch eher Typ Pulli- und Jogginghose, so wie ich.
Das muss aber natürlich nicht sein und vermutlich macht der Recruiter das ja auch nicht alleine.
Was ihr hingegen immer machen müsst, die Fähigkeiten an euren Job anpassen.
Bewerbt ihr euch für einen Python-Job, dann führt in den Jobs, die ihr gemacht habt,
gerne an, dass ihr mit Python die Server-Administration unterstützen müsstet.
Wenn ihr das natürlich auch gemacht habt.
Ausschmücken ist völlig okay und die Tätigkeiten an die Bewerbung angepasst zu beschreiben auch.
Lügen ist aber natürlich ein No-Go und das kommt sehr, sehr schnell ans Licht.
In der Liste der Programmiersprachen führt...
Dann müssten sich aber fast alle Recruiter bzw. Personalvermittler...
... sich jetzt langsam aber sicher mal zusammenreißen.
Weil in diesen ganzen Übersichten, die man da bekommt, ist sehr viel.
Sagen wir mal, gelogen ist vielleicht jetzt zu viel gesagt, aber...
... sehr fast stretched, also sehr, sehr so weit hergeholt.
Wir hatten mal einen, der hatte irgendwie Expert-Knowledge so nach dem Motto Ubuntu.
Und am Ende kam raus, da hat man Ubuntu in der VM installiert und so was in der Richtung.
Also da könnte man schon fast sagen, das war glatt gelogen.
Ja, die schönen das mega viel, ja.
Also insofern, naja.
...
Oder man macht das so wie ich, noch eine extra Skill-Liste hinten dran, die alles enthält, was sie hören wollen.
Was heißt alles, das stimmt ja gar nicht.
Nicht alles, was die hören wollen.
Alles, was irgendwie ein bisschen relevant für den Job ist und was auch stimmt.
Muss ja sagen, also ich habe ja hier meine Skill-Liste am Start, nicht exakt die, die ich geschickt habe.
Aber schön formatiert ist die Variante hier auch auf jeden Fall nicht.
Aber das stimmt ja, das ist ja tatsächlich die Wahrheit, was da drin steht.
Das größte Teil haben wir sogar hier im Stream schon zusammen gemacht.
Ja, das habe ich auch sortiert.
Was die Inhalte unter beruflicher Werdegang oder...
Da muss ich mal kurz sehen, habe ich da Englisch drinne stehen?
Nö.
Ich habe gar nichts zu Sprachen drinstehen.
We are all sitting in one boat.
Von meinen massive Englisch-Kenntnissen könnt ihr euch ja im Stream schon immer überzeugen.
Zumal ich mittlerweile sogar auch schon rein mit englischsprachigen Leuten
zum Beispiel von der Telekom Systeme eingerichtet habe und so was.
Das geht schon.
Gerade auf technischer Ebene ist das kein Problem mit den Leuten in Englisch zu kommunizieren.
Vor allem, wenn man ein bisschen Übung dann mit der Zeit bekommt.
Und vieles im technischen Bereich ist ja in Deutsch und Englisch jetzt gar keinen so großen Unterschied.
Ja, wenn man irgendwelche Packages installiert unter Linux und das...
Was das...
Wenn ich das jetzt beschreiben müsste auf Deutsch oder auf Englisch,
das würde wahrscheinlich kaum einen großen Unterschied machen.
Mit dem über seinen letzten Ferienausflug reden,
da hätte ich wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr Schwierigkeiten.
Wobei ich erstaunt bin, wie gut das funktioniert nach einer Weile.
Zum Beispiel, als ich noch auf die Gamescom gefahren bin.
Das mache ich ja schon einige Jahre nicht mehr.
Also so richtig mit Termine machen und Sachen sich angucken.
Das meiste, das hat er da auch auf Englisch gelabert.
Vor allem im Businessbereich.
Und das ging nach dem ersten halben Tag relativ gut.
Es ist alles eine Gewöhnungssache.
Man hat es irgendwie im Kopf, aber es fehlt schlicht und ergreifend die Praxis.
Konzentriert euch darauf, was für diesen Job, auf den ihr euch bewerbt, relevant ist.
Und formuliert das aus.
Es sollte immer dabei stehen, von wann bis wann ihr die Tätigkeit ausgeübt habt.
Dann hervorgehoben euer Jobtitel und anschließend in Stichpunkten,
was ihr dabei gemacht habt.
Als Beispiel, ihr seid Student und bewerbt euch auf einen Python-Job
als Backend-Entwickler.
Ihr habt also die Möglichkeit, ein paar eurer Module,
die genau damit zu tun haben, also Python, Web, Microservices,
Software-Development und vor allem auch praktische Projekte,
die Python-Job-Python benutzt haben, im Studium hervorzuheben.
Bitte nicht, ich habe blablabla, sondern wirklich nur Stichpunkte.
Habt ihr allerdings schon Berufsabkommen,
solltet ihr den Teil rauslassen und lieber eure Jobs detaillierter beschreiben.
Pro-Tip an der Stelle, Schlüsselleistungen wie
Verkäufe um x, y Prozent gesteigert,
sind ein echtes Verkaufsargument.
Und bei einer Bewerbung verkauft ihr euch selbst.
Bei der Ausbildung reicht dann von bis, welcher Abschluss, wo
und welche Schwerpunkte.
Noten könnt ihr dazuschreiben, sofern sie denn besser als 2.0 waren.
Ansonsten darf man die aber auch gerne weglassen.
Zusammengefasst ist das die STAR-Methode.
Situation, Task, Action und ...
Alter, jetzt wird es aber hyper-advanced.
Ist da nicht diese Spezialeinheit aus Resident Evil?
Also, wann und wo ihr wart, was war eure Aufgabe,
vor allem in Relevanz und Bezug auf den Job,
was habt ihr getan und was war euer Ergebnis.
Aber immer eben mit diesem Fokus auf den Job,
auf den ihr euch gerade bewerbt.
Spezielle Belohnungen könnt ihr aber natürlich auch sehr geben.
Jetzt wird es super, Agile Cloud-Native-Fiveheader.
So, das war's für heute.
Native-Fiveheader.
Soweit so basic.
Aber für viele ist die Situation längst nicht mehr so einfach.
Man ist Quereinsteiger, man ist Student
oder man hat noch gar keine Berufserfahrung.
Man hat sich aber vieles in der Freizeit beigebracht
und kann eigentlich mehr als dieser Lebenslauf darstellen.
Wie bilde ich das ab?
Hier habt ihr die Möglichkeit, wirklich zu scheinen
und v.a. herauszustechen.
Bitte seid selbstbewusst und versteckt euch nicht.
Wenn ihr was für euch selber gelernt habt,
ist das nicht weniger wert als durch eine Uni?
Meistens ist das sogar besser.
Wahrscheinlich sagt ihr das jetzt auch gleich.
Weil wenn du dich im Unternehmen
mit irgendeiner Technologie auseinandersetzen musst,
dann ja immer nur auf diesen Gesichtspunkt hin,
wie können wir das hier verwenden?
Oftmals hatten wir ein Thema,
was ich im Managed Kubernetes Service ist.
Wenn man sich das anguckt, muss man sich angucken,
wenn man sich das anguckt, kommt man zum Schluss,
vielleicht ist es sinnvoller,
gar keinen Cluster zu nehmen beim Cloud-Anbieter,
sondern einzelne Container-Workloads.
Ist für das Unternehmen sinnvoll,
aber trotzdem sinnvoll, sich damit beschäftigt zu haben.
Man lernt das deutlich besser,
hab ich zumindest die Erfahrung gemacht,
wenn man sich da für sich damit beschäftigt.
Eure Arbeit, auch in der Freizeit,
ist am Ende das, was euch besonders macht.
Solltet ihr das natürlich trotzdem aufschreiben.
Ich verrate euch jetzt aber einen Trick.
Man findet immer oder zumindest fast immer etwas,
das auch in der Informatik
oder eurem neuen Job relevant sein kann.
Das dürft ihr dann aber auch wirklich betonen.
Ein Beispiel, ihr seid Krankenpfleger
und wollten die Informatik wechseln.
Ziemlich sicher wart ihr als Krankenpfleger
einer großen Menge Stress ausgesetzt.
Der hat euch hoffentlich stärker gemacht.
Betont das gerne.
Vielleicht nicht so wörtlich, aber so...
Ich hab mich so abgefuckt, dass ich den Job gewechselt hab.
Dass der Recruiter das auch versteht.
Oder ihr wart z.B. auf dem Bau tätig.
Also habt ihr ziemlich sicher im Team gearbeitet.
Oder vielleicht sogar eins geleitet.
Selbst wenn ihr keine formale Ausbildung
in diesem Bereich habt,
habt ihr eventuell relevante Zertifikate
oder Schulungen gemacht.
Die dürfen gerne im Lebenslauf genannt werden
und im Anhang beiliegen.
Wichtig an der Stelle zählt nicht alles auf,
sondern wirklich nur die,
auf denen ihr euch dann am Ende auch bewerbt.
Ihr dürft aber gerne alle beilegen.
Und das ist im Endeffekt euer Portfolio.
An der Stelle,
Portfolios kann man auch gerne
z.B. auf GitHub zeigen.
Oder auf einer Website.
Generell, ohne Scheiß, Leute,
GitHub-Profil wird extrem gerne gesehen.
Deswegen hab ich ja meins auch ein bisschen hübsch
die Projekte sortiert,
dass nicht
die total ppeger Dinger da oben stehen.
Wenn ihr eine Website habt,
die euch sowieso schon gut darstellt,
dann verlinkt die.
Auch Projekte sind übrigens Erfahrungen,
worunter z.B. auch gerade die Website zählt.
Manche machen sogar einen eigenen Reiter
mit solchen Projekten.
Der sollte zwar weiter unten sein,
aber hier dürft ihr Open-Source-Projekte
oder private Projekte definitiv aufschreiben.
An der Stelle bitte keine Hello-World-Programme,
sondern richtige Projekte,
die wenn möglich auch live sind,
sodass ich sie sehen kann.
Das ist so viel wert
und ihr solltet das unbedingt nennen.
Wichtig dabei, gerne einen Link
zu eurem GitHub-Profil mit in den Lebenslauf rein,
wie schon gesagt,
oder den Link zu den jeweiligen Projekten
oder ganz einfach alle Informationen
auf LinkedIn packen.
Dazu bräuchte man erstmal
einen LinkedIn-Account.
Wobei, ich hab ja einen LinkedIn-Account.
Den kennt ihr, ne?
Mein LinkedIn-Account.
Der beste LinkedIn-Account überhaupt.
Ich bin noch nicht...
Ich hab das Passwort vergessen.
Ich kann noch nicht mal mehr recovern.
Ich kann noch nicht mal mehr
den Account recovern.
Keine Ahnung, ich hab das Login nicht mehr.
Ich find's halt witzig, ne?
Überall alles super seriös
und dann komm ich hier um die Ecke
aber das ist ja, wie gesagt,
ist ja eh nur ein Fake-Account,
den ich für ein Video erstellt hab mal.
Wirklichkeit Fähigkeiten zu bestätigen.
Dazu müsst ihr erstmal natürlich
Fähigkeiten angeben.
Lasst euch die dann aber von Kunden
auch wirklich bestätigen.
Kunden können auch Familienmitglieder sein,
für die ihr zum Beispiel eine Hobby-Website
geschrieben habt. Die darf auch gerne
genannt werden. Grundsätzlich solltet ihr
euch auf LinkedIn immer gut vernetzen.
Das ist mittlerweile eine wirklich wichtige Plattform für...
Ich hasse
LinkedIn und Social Media
Real-Life-Stells.
Wenn ich das unbedingt irgendwie aus
irgendwelchen Gründen machen muss,
werde ich das nie machen.
Recruiting geworden.
Selbst wenn ihr übrigens keine praktische
Projektarbeit vorweisen könnt,
habt ihr die Möglichkeit Programmiersprachen,
Frameworks und Tools zu nennen.
Bitte übertreibt es hier nicht.
Wie jetzt? Wie nicht übertreiben?
Das ist nicht übertrieben.
3 Seiten Skills.
Ups.
Noch mal. Da müssen die Skills rein,
die ihr in diesem Job
voraussichtlich brauchen. Alle.
Meistens steht sowas dabei.
In ein paar Sachen kann man sich aber auch erahnen.
Für den Python-Backend-Job
braucht ihr wahrscheinlich nicht eure
Zähne. Also für den Linux-System-Engineer
ist es enorm wichtig,
dass man weiß,
dass ich schon mal
was mit Vue.js gemacht habe.
Findet ihr nicht?
Frontend. Niemand kommt an Frontend
vorbei, Leute.
Oder es ist auch sehr wichtig,
dass ich schon mal
Steckdosen-Leisten mit Tasmota
geflasht habe.
Das muss man wissen. Logisch.
Aber ich habe es ja absichtlich so gemacht,
dass die wichtigen Sachen oben stehen.
Wann hast du was in Flutter gemacht?
Wie?
Bezichtigt ihr mich hier,
dass ich Mist erzähle?
Wir hatten mal einen Stream
darüber.
Aber
Ich habe sogar noch
den...
Ach hier.
Das ist doch. Das erste.
Passt doch.
Flutter.
Der ist natürlich...
Hast du einer schief auch verlinkt?
Nee.
Das habe ich auch nicht entwickelt.
Der Qtmod-Server ist aktuell
nicht so schnell, glaube ich.
Was hat er denn da wieder für
Anime-Upscaling-Sachen im Hintergrund laufen?
Dann ist für das Archiv kein...
Keine Rechenkapazität mehr übrig.
Ich glaube,
das ist das Problem.
Tja, gut.
Server dead.
Wie es aussieht. Wir können uns da sicher gucken.
Aber ja, ich gucke hier. Da sieht ihr es.
Ich habe einen Stream gemacht über Flutter.
Da haben wir nicht wirklich viel erstellt.
Außer...
Ist es wieder...
Procken? Null.
Außer eine App,
die...
Klips.
Wir haben eine App erstellt,
die sinnloses Zeug anzeigt.
Aber wir haben Flutter gemacht. So sieht es aus.
Ah, jetzt geht es. Okay.
Guck, so sieht unsere Flutter-App aus.
Die beste Desktop-
Flutter-App aller Zeiten.
Man konnte auf das Bild
drücken.
Und dann kam ein Sound. Fertig.
Best hier, guck.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Ja.
Richtig.
Also für die erste Flutter-App hier.
Bester Flutter-App überhaupt, oder?
Ich fasse es nicht.
Okay, weiter.
Okay.
Also, das Besteht.
Das Besteht, wenn ihr irgendwas mit Mikro-Controller machen müsst.
Speziell Quereinsteiger.
Habe ich das Gefühl, machen sich unfassbar viele Sorgen
über ihre Bewerbungen.
Auch Studenten gehören gelegentlich zu dieser Gruppe.
Eine Sache, die ich erst kürzlich
mit ein paar Kollegen besprochen habe,
nach Eurem ersten Job,
ist so etwas wie die Bachelor-Note
wirklich irrelevant.
Und der erste Job darf ruhig was kleines sein.
Werkstunden-Job, Aushilfs-Job.
Das können wir alles spielen.
Also, ich wurde bei meinem Lebenslauf auch gefragt.
Also da muss man sagen, da war der Personal
furchtbar korrekt.
Ich hab zum Beispiel
zwischen meiner Schulausbildung
und meiner Ausbildung so gut wie nichts reingeschrieben.
Oder wollten die ganz genau wissen,
was habe ich denn da gemacht?
Weil da ist eine Lücke im Lebenslauf.
Ich mein, vielleicht war ich ja
im Knast oder so, man weiß ja nie.
Um praktische Erfahrungen zu sammeln,
die man dann aufschreiben kann.
Noten sind nur dann wirklich wichtig,
wenn man nichts anderes hat,
um Euer Können einzuschätzen.
Denn darum geht es am Ende.
Nach dem Bachelor wird euch niemand mehr
nach der ABI-Note fragen, aber auch
Mich hat noch niemand, niemals,
noch niemals, jemand
nach meiner Abschlussnote in der IHK-Prüfung gefragt.
Ich weiß nicht,
wie es da bei euch aussieht, Leute.
Wurdet ihr jemals nach Eurer Abschlussnote gefragt?
Also ich, nie.
Weder bei meinem, weder beim Provider,
wo ich gearbeitet hab, noch bei der nichts
noch bei der jetzigen Bewerbung.
Nirgendwo.
Da hab ich noch nicht mal in den Lebenslauf geschrieben.
Oder hab ich?
Ausbildung. Nö.
Ich hab noch nicht mal die Note in den Lebenslauf geschrieben.
Quereinsteiger eigentlich nicht.
Projekte, die ihr gemacht habt,
oder sogar aktiv betreut hingegen,
die zeigen viel mehr.
Wo geht euer Herzblut rein?
Was macht euch Spaß? Was wir noch nicht besprochen haben,
sind die Hobbys.
Manche sagen, das muss ja in den Lebenslauf...
Nö, hab ich nicht reingeschrieben.
Ich hab, wie gesagt, ich hab mein Github Profil rein.
Und dass ich Webvideoproduzent bin,
halt, unter weitere Sachen.
Das wars. Hobbys,
wen juckt das?
Auch rein. Andere sagen nein.
Wenn es euch als Person widerspiegelt,
dann packt es ruhig rein, finde ich.
Macht euch durch den Lebenslauf
zu etwas Besonderem,
zu einer Person. Erstmal muss man den Recruiter
dazu bringen, zu lesen.
Und dann muss man aber auch wirklich rausstechen.
Wir sind übrigens in dem Zuge gerade
dran, die Skills in der
Bootstrap Academy mit einem Export zu versehen.
Damit man das Level, das man hat,
direkt in einem Lebenslauf auch...
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
IRK Zeugnis hat keiner gefragt.
Ja, ja.
Wie gesagt, mich auch.
Noch nie.
IRK Zeugnis, overrated.
Overrated, outdated,
jebaited.
Lass mich gerade mal kurz Wetter checken.
Ah, geht ja halbwegs.
Berufsschulzeugnis
hat mich auch nirgendwo gezeigt.
Also weder das IRK-Zeugnis, noch das
Berufsschul-Zeugnis
musste ich jemals irgendwo zeigen.
Ich mache ja auch keine BDO-Kreise.
Wer spielt noch BDO?
Niemand will das wissen.
So, was haben wir sonst, was wir uns angucken können?
Gutes Gehalt, viel Verantwortung.
Der Alltag als Lehrerin an der
Mittelschule. Oh, Lehrer!
Das ist ja das aller, aller Letzte,
was ich machen würde.
Die könnten mich mit Geld nicht
bestechen, dazu das zu machen.
Im Leben nicht.
Lehrer ist das beschissenste Beruf ever.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht, warum das Ebaro das
freiwillig machen will.
Aber gut, der wird sich schon überlegt haben.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal an, was
ein Lehrer oder eine
Lehrerin in dem Fall verdient.
Einen guten Morgen.
Mir reicht es locker, also es bleibt
wirklich sehr viel Geld
übrig.
Ich merke schon, dass es ein sehr
fordernder Beruf ist,
gerade auch wenn Schüler mit Problemen
zu einem kommen.
Ich bin die Felicitas,
ich bin 29 Jahre alt
und arbeite als
Mittelschullehrerin in
Obergünzburg im Allgäu.
Mittelschule?
Ist das in Österreich so was wie
Realschule oder so was wie
Hauptschule? Was ist da? Was ist
Mittelschule?
Oder ist das überhaupt in Österreich?
Äh, keine Ahnung.
Das ist in Bayern.
Ah.
Was ist
Mittelschule? Das ist
Hauptschule, okay. Ah, das ist quasi das,
was du nach der Grundschule machst.
Oh, hier.
Guten Morgen.
Morgen.
So, dann kopiere ich jetzt noch, was für
die Stunde zur Berufsorientierung.
Berufsorientierung, hoffentlich was
mit Holz.
Ich denke, dass ich mich allmählich auf dem Weg
ins Klassenzimmer mache.
Wir sind eben
die 8MA,
der Klasse im Entzug.
Die Mittelschule, früher hieß das
Hauptschule. Da gibt es zwei
Möglichkeiten, einen Schulabschluss zu machen.
Einmal nach der 9. Klasse und einmal nach der 10.
Klasse. Herzlich willkommen in
meinem Klassenzimmer.
Das ist auch was sehr Schönes. Das ist
mein Klassenzimmer, wo eben nur
meine Klasse eben Unterricht hat.
Ich hätte mir niemals vorstellen können,
am Gymnasium oder an der Realschule
zu unterrichten, weil das Schöne hier an
der Mittelschule ist, dass ich sehr
viele Stunden in meiner eigenen
Klasse unterrichte.
Also ich habe zum Beispiel Mathe und Deutsch.
Da kennt man die üblichen Verdächtigen schon.
Und dieses Fach mit
Geschichte und Geografie, Berufsorientierung.
Und ich sehe sie jeden Tag.
Und dadurch lerne ich es einfach sehr
gut kennen.
So, alles aus der Hand legen bitte,
Tobias.
Ich wünsche Ihnen einen guten Morgen.
Ich heiße 18 mal. Guten Morgen.
Was zum...
Was ist das?
Wie jetzt?
Hä?
Was zum Teufel ist das jetzt gewesen?
Geht das
rund um, dass jeder im Namen der Klasse
Guten Morgen... Warum sagt das nicht?
Also wir haben in der Schule das zusammengesagt.
Du weißt, was ich...
Ja, guten Morgen...
Guten Morgen, Herr Müller, so nach dem Motto.
Dann legen wir los mit Mathe.
Wollen wir wenden, die spielen alle Fortnite?
Die gesamte...
Die gesamte Link... Also bis auf das
Mittel alle hier. Alle hatten
Fortnite-Crime.
Wir werden die Körper jetzt wiederholen.
Die Schüler an der Mittelschule sind
eher verschieden.
Die Herausforderung beim Unterrichter
liegt meistens tatsächlich darin,
den Unterricht so zu gestalten, dass
alle Schüler, egal
wie gut sie in irgendeinem Fach sind, egal
welche Vorkennnisse da sind, dass alle
am gleichen Ziel ankommen.
Und dann bei jedem einfach mal so ein bisschen
zählen. Nehmen wir wirklich den
Fachbegriff von vorher, dass es viele
Flächen sind.
Wenn man eben schon sagen muss, dass er seinen Namen
eintragen muss, dann ist glaube ich alles verloren, oder?
Eder, genau.
Okay, so.
Der meister Eder.
Wer noch nicht alles hat, füllt mit auf
und denkt weiter mit. Ist der Würfel
ein Prisma oder ein Spitzkörper?
Manuel?
Dieser Körper hat
drei Flächen.
Keine Ecken.
Und zwei Kanten.
Timo?
Einmal lüften.
Wer aufs Klo muss ganz schnell aufs Klo.
Ich habe eine Freistunde jetzt dann
und warte, bis die englische Lehrerin da ist.
Ihr Lieben, bitte nach der Pause
pünktlich
nach oben kommen.
Gut.
Dann bis später. Die Stunde jetzt
will ich nutzen. Ein bisschen was für morgen machen
auch. Schon, dass es nachmittags nicht ganz so geht.
Alleine, dass ich den ganzen Tag
mich da irgendwie mit so halbstarken
auseinandersetzen muss, wird mir extrem
auf den Sack gehen.
Ich arbeite auch am Freitag und am
Samstag und am Sonntag. Und die machen noch einen
umgänglichen Eindruck jetzt.
Und auch in den Ferien. Also dieses
Gerücht, ja, nachmittags immer frei
und in den Ferien und keine Ahnung, wieviel Tage
Urlaub, das stimmt nicht.
Ja, würde
ich jetzt auch sagen. Also am Donnerstag mache ich Pausenaufsicht
und das ist tatsächlich
am ganzen Schultag das
anstrengendste. Weil es
laut ist, weil es viele Schüler sind, weil viel passieren
kann.
Du bist in
Technik.
Aber du bist Technik.
Bist du im Donnerstagskurs?
Nee, dann passt.
Dann hast du nach der fünften Stunde Ende.
Aber Pause ist jetzt aus, also
ab nach oben.
Ich glaube, dass es ein echt
anstrengender Job ist.
Dann legen wir los.
Eine,
die ich im Leben nicht machen würde.
Aber gut, hat ja jeder unterschiedliche
Veranlagungen.
Ich mag meine Schüler sehr gern.
Ich glaube, dass das auch das Wertvolle an dem Beruf
ist. Einfach, dass es Jugendliche sind,
die nicht nur in die Schule kommen
für den Unterricht, sondern durchaus
auch, weil da die Lehrer sind.
Weil sie den Lehrern auch Dinge erzählen
können. Manche bringen einem sehr viel Vertrauen
auch entgegen. Wir sind ja oft
die neben den Eltern, die Erwachsenen,
die sie einfach am meisten sehen.
Stimmt voll.
Beginnen wir die letzte Stunde
mit, also
zur Berufsorientierung.
Lohnt sich das?
Werden wir anschauen. Zwei Folgen
schaffen wir heute zeitlich.
Ah!
Das ist das Beste. Videos
angucken.
Sehr gut. Videos angucken
ist nice. Da kann man ein bisschen
chillen als Lehrer.
Früher, bei uns,
war das dann immer noch so,
dass wir in Physik und so teilweise
so komische, richtige Oldschool
Sachen von Videorekordern
geguckt haben.
Wo dann, wo dann
irgendwelche Aufnahmen von 1960
oder was auch immer
gezeigt wurden, das Elektron
und sowas.
Ja, bei Lohnt sich das wird das Gehalt
auch mit thematisiert, was ich persönlich
sehr wichtig finde.
Ich meine, ein Beruf kann sehr viel Spaß machen,
ganz treu sein, aber wenn man halt so wenig
verdient, dass es vielleicht schwierig wird,
dann ist das halt auch irgendwie ein K.O.-Kriterium, finde ich,
für einen Beruf. Deswegen ist es, diese Lohnt sich das
wenig. Deswegen finde ich, deswegen finde ich
kacke, dass so viele Berufe,
die eigentlich wichtige Sachen machen,
von Monat zu Monat quasi
muss Null auf dem Konto haben. Und eigentlich
nichts wirklich machen können, außer arbeiten und
überleben.
Ah, die können nicht einfach Video gucken
und abchillen, nein das geht nicht.
Die müssen dann auch noch was ausfüllen,
wo dann am Ende wahrscheinlich sogar noch geguckt wird
und gefragt wird.
Der Küchenplaner, das Video kennen wir noch.
Der Küchenplaner.
Der Küchenplaner, das ist der mit der
15.000 Euro Kaffeemaschine oder der
23.000 Euro Kaffeemaschine mit der
ultra teuren Kaffeemaschine.
Was habt ihr notiert, Arbeitszeiten
dieses Küchenplanes?
Johannes?
40 bis 50 Stunden in der Woche.
Zum Gehalt.
Ich habe immer eine der ersten Fragen,
was verdient man da? Reicht mir das später aus?
Kannst du dir
vorstellen, in
diesem Beruf zu arbeiten? Ja?
Vielleicht nein. Wer kann sich das vorstellen?
Ja?
Bei dir Angelina? Warum
ja? Ja, ich mag es aus sowas etwas gestalten.
Also das Kreative
an dem Beruf auf jeden Fall. Okay.
Ich mag vor allem mit 21.000 Euro
Kaffeemaschine.
Was muss sie machen, damit sie
weiß, welche Behandlung?
Das mag ich nicht, ich trinke eigentlich gar keinen Kaffee.
Die Behandlung hilft. Sie hört zu, also
er beschreibt sein Problem und
genau sie untersucht.
Wer kann sich vorstellen,
in diesem Beruf zu arbeiten?
Menschenkontakt, ein bisschen medizinisch.
Mom KS, Alter!
Menschenkontakt, das ist ja das Allerschlimmste.
Gar niemand, okay.
Da hätte ich gerne ein paar Stichproben. Pascal,
warum nein?
Okay, dann haben wir da auch ein bisschen
einen Einblick gekickt.
Zu viel Kontakt mit Menschen. Pascal,
ich glaube, der weiß,
wie es läuft. Heute war ein sehr guter
Schultag, weil alles
nach Plan funktioniert hat.
Ich bin mit all meinen Inhalten
durchgekommen, alles ist im Heft,
alles passt wirklich gut.
Und jetzt auch am Ende noch waren sie
wirklich sehr konzentriert.
Gigachat Pascal. Bis morgen.
Ich bin jetzt
Brutto
bei knapp
4350 Euro.
Familienzuschlag ist sogar auch noch dabei.
Das sind bei mir 78 Euro, weil ich
eben verheiratet bin. Den gibt es dann da noch dazu.
Und genau nach Abzug
von allen Steuern bleibt
netto ungefähr 3300.
Okay,
das liegt aber bei ihr daran, dass sie
verheiratet ist und dass sie wahrscheinlich
Beamtenlehrer-Dings ist.
Also das sieht jetzt im Brutto
in sich nicht so hoch aus, es
bezahlt aber nicht so viele Steuern, dementsprechend
bleibt netto ganz gut was übrig.
Und dann muss ich aber
halt die private Krankenversicherung noch abziehen.
Ah, ja, okay.
Wir machen das dann quasi mit dem Nettogehalt.
Das sind knapp 280 Euro
bei mir, also ungefähr
3000 Netto habe ich
dann einen Monat zur Verfügung.
Da muss ich sagen,
alles richtig gemacht. Ich muss
nur vier Tage die Woche arbeiten
und ich habe keinen oder wenig
Menschenkontakt und ich verdiene mehr.
Also insofern easy.
Ich merke schon, dass es
ein sehr fordernder Beruf ist,
auch wenn Schüler mit Problemen zu einem kommen.
Das nimmt einen ja mit, man mag die Schüler ja.
Und oft ist es schwer,
dass dann auch, okay, und jetzt war ich heim,
jetzt lasse ich liegen und mache morgen weiter.
Das finde ich schwer.
Ob ich es bis zum Ruhestand,
bis zur Pension machen will,
die Frage ist,
wenn sie es bis zur
Pension macht,
dann wahrscheinlich nicht so motiviert
wie jetzt, weil die macht ja schon den Eindruck,
als finden sie es noch nice.
Das mache ich mir sehr oft.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich es bis,
also bin ich 65, 67,
ich glaube, das schaffe ich.
Ja, Flozan, das stimmt. Also insgesamt,
so gesellschaftlich gesehen, ist ihr Job
wahrscheinlich wichtiger als meiner.
Da mache ich mir keine Illusion.
Man könnte sogar vielleicht sagen,
sie hat mehr Verantwortung.
Klar, bei uns ist das Problem, wenn was kaputt geht,
dann kostet es gleich Millionen.
Also rein finanziell habe ich da sicherlich
mehr Verantwortung, allerdings so
für, auf menschlicher
Ebene und für die Kinder
und für, muss man Jugendlichen sagen,
also für die Gesamtheit
so an sich, hat sie sicherlich
mehr Verantwortung als ich
in dem Job. Nicht.
Hallo Mausi.
Du hast uns gewartet, Mausi.
Ich bin zu Hause.
Frankasy, Frankasy, Frankasy.
Wobei, das war ein zu großer Hund.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Hi.
Ich habe Pitman dabei.
Okay, das ist kein großer Hund, das ist ein hässlicher Hund.
Exzellent.
Ja, dann einen guten Appetit.
Was sind denn eigentlich
ihre Fächer?
Mathe?
Mathe,
Musik und
Berufsorient?
Was macht die denn eigentlich?
Mathe?
Oder sowas in der Richtung zumindest?
Fünfte Klasse und 7, 8, 9
die Musikkurse.
Fast die Hälfte meiner gesamten Unterrichtszeit
ist für Musikunterricht.
Das war auch eine ursprüngliche
Unterricht. Das war auch an der Uni mein Hauptfach.
Und das ist schon auch
sehr aufwändig immer.
Das ist mein Zwei-Rad.
Ich meine, jetzt bin ich auf dem Weg zum Vier-Radfahren.
Im Winter kann ich nicht Motorradfahren.
Und die darf ich leider erst ab April
fahren. Jetzt ist auch noch viel zu
kalt, aber da freue ich mich schon,
wenn ich da wieder loslegen kann.
Ich fahre total
gern Kart,
weil ich gern schnell fahre.
Beim Autofahren kann man das nicht so gut machen,
nur beim Kartfahren eben.
Wann haben die Mittag gegessen? 14.30 war die schon daheim?
Oder wann war das?
14.30,
oder?
Da träumen ja viele von 14.30
schon daheim zu sein.
Ihr Kerl ist wahrscheinlich auch
Lehrer, sonst war es in der Richtung, keine Ahnung,
weil er ist auch 14.30 schon daheim oder hat Mittagspause.
14.30 ist natürlich
supergeil, 14.30 schon zuhause zu sein.
Und auch der
Nervenkitzel, der
Ehrgeiz, dieses schneller sein als
letztes Mal, schneller sein als andere,
andere überholen auch auf jeden Fall.
Lehrer haben Vormittagsrecht
und Nachmittagsfreiheit.
Das macht mir schon
sehr Spaß. Also gemütlich fahren
werde ich nicht.
Ja,
ich muss jetzt gleich mal in meine Rundenzeit.
Ich war
38,
23.
Also hast du es doch geschafft.
38,
23.
Das ist so geil.
Der Beruf
Mittelschullehrer
lohnt sich für mich
finanziell auf jeden Fall.
Das ist ein sehr gutes Gehalt.
Es ist ein sehr gutes Gehalt.
Auch persönlich lohnt es sich,
wenn man Jugendliche mag und mit ihnen arbeitet.
Da hört es bei
mir schon auf.
Wenn man Jugendliche
mag.
Ich mag keine Kinder,
ich mag keine Jugendliche und ich mag eigentlich
auch keine Erwachsenen. Ich mag gar keine.
Aber wenn ich es mir aussuchen dürfte, dann mag ich
Jugendliche wahrscheinlich am wenigsten.
Dann gibt es einem sehr viel.
Aktuell sage ich wirklich,
der Beruf lohnt sich für mich.
Jetzt wird gespart.
Das war
mein Alltag als Mittelschullehrerin.
Ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen.
Also
war ja alles nachvollziehbar, was ich echt cringe fand,
war
Guten Morgen im Name der Klasse 8a.
Das war echt komisch.
Ich weiß nicht.
Da fand ich das bei uns besser,
dass alle gesagt haben, guten Morgen, Blablablabla
und gut ist. Das hatte eh schon keiner
Bock drauf gehabt.
Ja.
So Spiele in Richtung
Unreal Tournament und Quake 3
gibt es ja schon eine Weile nicht mehr.
Ja stimmt, private Krankenkassen
ist schon nice. Es ist schon wirklich nice.
Also
das sieht jetzt protomäßig nicht so viel aus.
Aber
unter dem Strich
kommt ganz gut was raus.
Und private Krankenversicherung ist natürlich auch nicht
nicht verkehrt.
Kannst du mal hier was?
Ist der Hass auf TikTok berecht?
Oh nee, auf TikTok habe ich jetzt keinen Bock.
TikTok mache ich in
großen Bohrungen jetzt rum.
No-Pos.
Haben wir noch irgendwas
Technisches, was wir uns angucken können?
Mit diesem Trick bereits eine
PC.
Streaming.
Can Windows 98
run on a new modern PC 2023?
Hi Guys.
Oh.
Hm.
Ich tippe mal drauf, es klappt nicht.
InnaVM.
Ja, InnaVM läuft das.
In this video I tried to install
Windows 11 on my PC.
So I thought it will be nice to
film a video about...
Install...
Ich scroll mal ein bisschen vor.
Ich will mal gucken, ob das klappt.
Hat die Installation funktioniert?
Welcome to Microsoft Windows
98. Please sit back and relax
while Windows 98
runs on your modern PC.
Oh, have you seen this message?
Try Commander Key.
It's working well with it.
Zero M.
It was loaded
successfully. We did it.
Unbelievable.
I need more attention to a different
language. I've spent a lot of time
trying to run Windows 98 and I
had to use different versions
of the system to succeed.
Let's open my computer properties.
And here is AMD 5,
2400G and 1.5
GB of RAM. It's very strange
because... Ah.
Mit mehr RAM ist das Ganze wohl
nicht gebootert, hä?
The patch map is already installed here
with only one 4 GB RAM stick
connected to the motherboard.
Zu viel RAM da ist gekrasht.
Ansonsten... Naja, gut.
Wundert mich nicht.
Das sind aktuell die besten Smartphones.
Das muss ich mir nicht angucken, weil...
Wobei mich tatsächlich interessiert.
Muss ich mir nicht angucken, weil ich habe mir jetzt ein neues iPhone gekauft
und das bleibt jetzt auch erst mal.
Ich werde mir jetzt kein weiteres Smartphone kaufen.
Nur weil in irgendeinem Video vielleicht jemand sagt
Es gibt ein besseres.
Gibt's ja auch.
Also, mit Sicherheit. Je nachdem was
man haben will, ist das ja eine individuelle
Geschichte. Wenn man zum Beispiel
eher auf Android-Geräte
guckt, ist man natürlich mit dem iPhone nicht glücklich.
Oder wenn man Sachen machen will,
die mit iOS nicht gescheit funktionieren,
aber mit Android. Oder umgedreht, wenn man
spezielle Apps haben will, die es nur unter iOS gibt,
ist ja sehr
individuell, was
das beste Smartphone ist und die beste
Plattform auf dem Smartphone.
Da macht es auch gar keinen Sinn, dass jetzt
irgendwelche Android-Leute sagen, null, wie kann man
iOS verwenden und irgendwelche iOS-Leute
sagen, alter, Android,
wie kann man das nur benutzen? Das macht überhaupt keinen
Sinn. Man sollte das benutzen,
was für einen persönlich am besten ist,
mit seinen Anforderungen.
Deswegen habe ich auch iOS-Geräte
und Android-Geräte, weil
beides seine Daseinsberechtigung
hat. Das einzige, was ich nicht habe, ist Windows
Phone, weil ich glaube, das gibt es auch gar nicht mehr.
Und wozu?
Das war ja noch nie sonderlich sinnvoll.
Traviz!
Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub.
Mal kurz reingucken. Ich
vermute, dass ich wieder die Hälfte übersehen
habe an Subscriptions.
Ja.
Marvelous Marshmallow, danke für den Sub.
Seto,
Porgas, Janfred,
Sebasushan,
das war gestern schon.
Nicht mit
Sebaro zu verwechseln.
Nicht nur diplomatisch, das ist
ja wirklich so.
Quatsch,
das ist überhaupt nicht so. Du kannst unter
Android Sachen machen, die du unter iOS nicht machen kannst.
Zum Beispiel das
ganze Thema Automatisierung ist unter
Android einfach tausendmal
mehr möglich und besser als
unter iOS.
Twigsorn,
Pogas Subscription, dankeschön.
So.
Scam Train ist am Start.
Haben wir noch irgendwas spannendes, was wir gucken
können? Leute, wisst ihr was? Es ist noch nicht mal
11 Uhr und ich hab schon Hunger.
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Das stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
War Zeitumstellung?
Zeitumstellung?
Was ist denn die?
Ah nächste Woche.
Nächste Woche Sonntag ist die Zeitumstellung erst.
Ok.
Dann wieder Oktober.
Was macht eigentlich die
Abschaffung der Zeitumstellung?
Wie sieht es da eigentlich aus?
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht, oder?
Da passiert nichts, ja das wundert mich auch nicht.
Why I code on Linux instead of
Windows, ja.
Weil es besser ist.
Privacy,
Reliability, Hardware,
Community,
Customization, das auf jeden Fall.
Terminal, ja.
Customization, Terminal geh ich auf jeden Fall mit.
Community kommt drauf an, wo man da
unterwegs ist.
Hardware, naja ok.
Das macht für mich keinen Unterschied.
Reliability, das auf jeden Fall auch.
Privacy auch im Endeffekt, ja.
Ist schon, ist schon wahr.
Ganz ehrlich, warum ich am liebsten
unter Linux entwickeln und die Sachen so
einfach ist, weil mir Linux am wenigsten
auf den Sack geht. Das ist die
ehrliche Antwort.
Und Windows stört mich.
Zum Beispiel, dass ich letztens auf einmal
so ein komisches Searchbar im Hintergrund hatte,
wo ich mich so, wo kommt die her?
Wir gucken das nicht, ich habe keinen Bock
auf noch mehr Chat-GPT-Videos.
Das mir YouTube ein bisschen was
anderes empfiehlt.
700 Euro ICE3-Flop, ja.
Modelleisenbahn, Poggers.
Was verdient ein Programmierer?
Das haben wir uns schon angeguckt.
Wenn du Linux sagst, er soll
ETC löschen, dann macht es das auch.
Ja, wobei, ich habe
noch ein paar ETCs.
Ja, wobei, ich da
einen Tipp für euch habe.
Wenn wir gerade
dabei sind, wenn ihr schon mal
aus Versehen
Verzeichnisse gelöscht habt,
dann kann ich euch einen Kompromiss empfehlen.
Es gibt Leute, die sagen,
hey, nimm was,
was RM
ersetzt, zum Beispiel so was hier
und das quasi RM
alias auf Trash
und das dann nur noch in Papierkorb schmeißt
und RM gar nicht mal wirklich löscht.
Find ich gar nicht so sinnvoll.
Es gibt
ein Trick.
Was ist das für ein Pull-Request?
Es gibt ein Trick für RM,
dass ihr RM sicherer machen könnt
und trotzdem, dass ihr keinen Papierkorb braucht.
Ihr könnt RM
überschreiben, und zwar mit RM
selber, allerdings
mit RM
minus groß i.
Was macht RM minus groß i?
Das schaltet RM auf
Interactive, allerdings
nicht einfach nur auf Interactive, sondern
auf
prompt once before removing more than three
files, also sprich
es fragt euch nur,
wenn RM mehr als drei Dateien entfernen würde
oder wenn ihr ein Verzeichnis
löscht.
So, und warum habe ich das
überschrieben und mache nicht einfach
minus i dran? Naja,
weil, wenn man RM minus RF
angibt, hier machen wir Temp,
wenn ihr, ich mache jetzt mal das so
direkt, wenn ihr RM minus RF
macht,
dann ist der Ordner
logischerweise weg.
Wenn ihr
minus i macht,
dann fragt ihr euch, dann sagt ihr yes.
So, und jetzt kommt der Hit,
wenn ihr minus i vorne macht,
dann funktioniert es nicht.
Deswegen musste ich so einen
eigenen Overload quasi
basteln, weil
das letzte, was du angibst,
also wie
zerstörerisch RM
sein soll, zählt.
Wenn minus f
hinter minus i steht, dann überschreibt
minus f minus i und wenn
minus i hinten steht, überschreibt minus
i minus f,
sodass aber trotzdem Recurse,
löschen und so noch funktioniert und dadurch
kann man weiterhin das machen,
mk dir Temp, dadurch kann man
das machen, was man gewöhnt ist, allerdings
ich werde trotzdem gefragt, bevor
ich Recursive entfernen will.
Ja, das finde ich ist eine ganz gute Sache,
einfach so ein Alias, beziehungsweise
ein Alias kann man nicht machen, weil man die
Argumente übergeben muss, einfach
in seiner Shell RM
überschreiben, overloaden
quasi und dann
wirst du immer gefragt, wenn du Recursive
Ordner überschreiben willst. So.
Und dann hast du natürlich noch das Problem,
was ist, wenn RM
anfängt zu nerven?
Das ist auch ganz gut, so wir kopieren
uns jetzt mal hier einen Git
Repo, da sind ja viele
Dateien drinne.
Kekl, so, beste. Wenn ich jetzt
sag RM minus f Kekl, dann
sagt er mir Recursive, Recursive,
Recursive, das ist nervig,
ne? Leute, das ist,
das ist eklig, oder?
Dass ich dann so oft Yes
drücken muss. So. Und die
einfachste Variante dazu ist,
einfach nichts zu machen und Yes
nach RM zu palpen.
Das heißt, so stellst du sicher,
dass du wirklich genau
sicher bist, ja, ich weiß, was ich
mache und ich will das jetzt auch
machen.
Und da kannst du nicht aus Versehen irgendwas kaputt
Also ich finde, das ist
besser und
angenehmer als mit einem Papierkorb.
Also im Prinzip einfach nur
in seiner Shell-Config RM überschreiben
damit.
Ich bin mir übrigens nicht sicher.
Ich bin mir übrigens nicht sicher, ob
das alle, ja,
so Sonderfälle abdeckt. Das habe
ich mir ausgedacht.
Wie man die
Parameter hier übergeben kann. Ich bin
mir nicht sicher, ob das klar
kommt. Vielleicht sollte ich es noch
Quoten, dass es, oder ne, wenn ich
Quote klappt es nicht. Keine Ahnung. Es könnte sein, dass es
Probleme hat mit Leerzeichen oder mit
eskepten Sachen oder so.
Da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, wie safe das ist.
Also besser ist,
anstatt das einfach zu übernehmen, guck nochmal
bei Stackoverflow, was die so vorschlagen.
Aber vom Ansatz her finde ich
das eine gute, eine gute
Variante. Ja, und es hat den Vorteil
dadurch, dass es in eurer
Shell-RC definiert ist,
wenn ihr Skripte ausführt, dann ist es das ganz
normale RM.
So viel zum Thema RM.
Weiß gar nicht, wie wir jetzt da drauf gekommen sind.
Wie sind wir da drauf gekommen?
Weiß ich nicht, aber dann
kann ich empfehlen.
Einfach nie Fehler tippen. Ja, das ist
auch eine gute Idee.
Unit-Test zu Bash-Skript.
Auf geht's.
Das passiert da weniger,
weil es dich ja nur fragt,
wenn du mehr als drei Dateien ohne
ein Verzeichnis löscht.
Bei normalen RMs fragt es dich
gar nicht.
Also da gewöhnst du dich auch nicht so sehr
dran. Man könnte übrigens
noch einen Delay einbauen.
Also wer gar
Schiss hat, dass er das Falsche
löscht, der könnte auch noch
einen Delay einbauen.
Nach dem Motto, bist du dir sicher?
Yes. Wirklich.
Einfach bevor...
Ja gut, das ist in der RM nicht eingebaut.
Da müsstest du dir selbst was drum herum
skripten. Das ist dann tatsächlich gar nicht so
gar nicht so einfach.
Kann es RM
show number
of files?
Ja gut, dass man das nach WC pipen kann,
nachdem es zu spät ist, weiß ich.
Es gibt keinen Dry-Run
für RM, oder?
Gibt es einen Dry-Run?
Nein,
es gibt keinen Dry-Run für RM,
oder?
Gibt es einen Dry-Run?
Ne, das funktioniert so nicht.
Das funktioniert so nicht.
Ja, oder man überschreibt das.
Dann kannst du RM nicht mehr verwenden, da musst du irgendein RM
Replacement verwenden, was die Sachen in
Papierkopf verschiebt.
Was ich nicht so schön bin. Ja,
das geht natürlich.
Ja.
Ja, warum gibt es eigentlich
keinen Dry-Run?
RM Dry-Run!
Ja, super, was drum herum
geskripte, das kriege ich auch gemacht.
Ja.
Ja, das geht natürlich.
Was ich cool finde,
ne, das funktioniert nicht.
Das funktioniert so nicht.
Weil, da kriegst du
Rekursive aus dem Verzeichnis, das
funktioniert so nicht.
Da kannst du halt nicht RM verwenden, da musst du irgendwas
benutzen, was RM
quasi simuliert,
aber in Wirklichkeit in Papierkopf verschiebt.
Und dann halt Jahr darauf gucken,
dass es nur in deiner Shell-RC verlinkt
ist und nicht irgendwie global fürs Kripte.
MV, ne, funktioniert auch nicht.
MV hat andere Parameter als RM.
Ja.
Aber damit, also mit der Kombination
mit dem Interactive, fahre ich eigentlich
ganz gut, muss ich sagen.
Ist jetzt noch nichts aus Versehen gelöscht.
Außerdem mache ich regelmäßig Snapshots
von meiner VM.
Und da ist das
kein Problem.
Selbst wenn ich aus Versehen was lösche.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
So, YouTube, haben wir noch
irgendwas wirklich Interessantes, komm,
zeig doch mal irgendwas, Mensch.
Guck mal von hinten.
Reich werden
als Informatiker.
Was war das?
Hab ich das gerade richtig gelesen?
Wo ist das denn?
Hat er den?
Nee, das meine ich nicht.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Was auch immer.
Pepega YouTube
Einfach kein RM verwenden.
Ja.
Dann kannst du auch nichts löschen.
Oder du kannst was anderes verwenden
als RM. Wobei ehrlich gesagt,
ich bin kein Fan von
zu viel customisern.
Weil
wenn du nur Linux auf dem Desktop
beziehungsweise zum entwickeln verwendest und nicht
quasi auch noch als Linux
Admin arbeitest,
kannst du das machen. Aber ansonsten
finde ich gar so viel customisern auch blöd,
weil
dann verlierst du die anderen Sachen,
die du dann auf dem Server brauchst, wo es
Default ist. Ist übrigens auch der Grund,
warum ich mein Vim nicht mehr so
krass customisert habe wie früher, nur ein paar Sachen.
Dass ich das
möglichst Raw benutzen muss, dass ich auch auf
Servern und anderen Systemen Remote gut klarkomme.
Nee, bringt sie an der Stelle
auch nicht. Dann fragt sie sich
für jede Datei. Es ging ja darum,
warum RM nicht einfach einplanten kann,
wie viele es löschen würde. Das wäre natürlich sehr
sinnvoll.
Okay, GitHub, RM.
Wo wird RM gehostet
eigentlich?
RM Tool, Linux.
Das gehört bestimmt zu
GNU. Oh nee, allow me to
interject for a moment.
Da muss ich Richard Stalman
Pull Request schicken dafür, um das einzubauen.
Ich glaube, ich lasse es.
Aber das wäre tatsächlich ganz praktisch, wenn der RM anzeigen
könnte. Okay.
Dieses Verzeichnis, also dieses RM würde
jetzt 2350 Dateien löschen.
Gehört zu Binutils. Okay, wo ist Binutils
gehostet?
Bestimmt nicht auf GitHub, oder?
Unofficial Mirror.
GNU Binutils.
RM.
Gehört RM dazu? Nee.
Nein, nein, nein.
Wie ist das denn? Contribute
to RM. Wie würde das funktionieren?
Wo gehört das dazu überhaupt?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Man könnte auch einfach
einen der 3000 RM Replacements
benutzen.
Nee, anscheinend nicht. Ich hätte jetzt auch
aus dem Bauch vermutet.
Ja, mit Find.
Aber da musst du selbst was drum herum stricken.
Wie gesagt, es wäre cooler,
wenn das RM selbst
Core Utils. Okay.
Wo sind die gehostet?
GNU Core Utils.
Source Code.
Okay, die sind
auf GitHub?
Ach, mirrored. Okay.
Die sind so modern?
Hä?
Soll das irgendein Joke sein, weil die
Dinger so langsam sind, oder?
Okay,
ich habe jetzt
die Dinger.
Okay, man kann tatsächlich hier
Sachen einreichen für RM.
Mach ich nicht. Bin ja auch viel zu kacke,
was C-Programmieren angeht.
Man chat GPT.
Das waren wir jetzt nicht. Warte, ich gehe jetzt
was fuddern. Es ist zwar noch eine halbe Stunde
hin, aber
mal gucken.
Ja, das wäre relativ easy.
Das will ich aber nicht, wenn schon verwende ich
irgendein RM Replacement oder so.
Ich gehe jetzt was fuddern.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher. Nee,
heute nicht. Heute nicht.
Heute gibt es
Nudeln mit Lachs.
Tatsächlich, jetzt wo du es sagst.
Korrekt.
Vielleicht basteln wir nachher noch
ein bisschen was. Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Ich habe gesehen,
Leute, meine Frage für die gestern bei
meinem Kubernetes Stream dabei waren. Ich habe gesehen,
die Kubernetes Streams gucken so
50, 60 Leute
im Durchschnitt weniger als die anderen
Technik Streams. Ich glaube,
das ist einfach ein sehr advancedes Thema.
Es mag aber auch daran liegen,
dass ich etwas planloser bin
im Vergleich zu zum Beispiel
irgendwelche anderen
Linux basierten Themen.
Also, ich bin
ein bisschen langsamer, wenn ich
Kubernetes Stream mache.
Da muss ich ein paar Sachen nachgucken. Sachen funktioniert nicht.
Bei anderen Streams geht es ja
meistens relativ zack, zack, weil ich da 100%
weiß, was ich mache. Bei Kubernetes
ist das halt manchmal so der Fehler im
Detail. Und...
Ne, aufhören will ich nicht.
Ich überlege gerade, wie man
das besser machen könnte. Ich glaube,
ich glaube, am sinnvollsten wäre es,
wenn ich mir im Vorfeld tatsächlich
ein Thema ausdenke
und mal
grob überlege...
Ja, genau. Und mal grob
überlege, was wir denn jetzt machen.
Dann Schritt für Schritt mir das im Vorfeld schon mal aufschreiben.
Ja, wenn es danach geht...
Wenn es danach geht, dürften wir wahrscheinlich 90% der
Sachen nicht machen.
Das ist nicht so einfach bei dem
Thema, weil viele Sachen, von denen ich denke,
dass sie einfach funktionieren,
am Ende dann doch nicht so einfach funktionieren,
weil man irgendwo irgendwas in irgendeinem
Jammele-File in der falschen Reihenfolge
stehen hat oder so.
Ich habe ja schon einen groben Plan, was ich machen will.
Ja.
Ja, das habe ich im Stream vorher gezeigt.
Ich muss mal gucken. Vielleicht kriegen wir das in Zukunft
noch besser hin.
Ich muss, glaube ich,
immer einen funktionierenden Stand
haben, wenn wir mit einem Stream aufhören und dann
die ersten
20 Minuten erklären, was wir denn jetzt schon
haben und wie es
funktioniert. Jedes Mal, so ungefähr.
Und dann, dass man dann weiter machen kann an der Stelle.
Zumindest, ich habe mir einen neuen
Google-Account gemacht, mit
300 Dollar
Google Cloud Startguthaben. Das heißt, wir werden
uns in einem der nächsten
Streams dann auch mal Google Cloud
Kubernetes-Stells angucken.
Ach so, Wubblors Recap.
Wubblors Recap.
Wo kann man das nochmal sehen?
Recap.
Wie geht das?
Recap?
Einfach so? Nee.
Ja. Recap.
Ach hier, so. Recap
davor.
Äh.
Alles klar.
Muss man dazu
eingeloggt sein?
Da muss man eingeloggt sein, ne?
Gut, dann können wir es uns zusammen nicht angucken.
Bin ich nicht eingeloggt auf dem
Streaming-Rechner. Hab ich auch nicht
vor.
Alles klar, Leute. Wir sehen uns. Bis denn. Macht's
gut. See you.